hey
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay
b that is not that is not cool i'm tired
of you guys watching and not subscribing
subscribe to the channel
so um today we have a couple
announcements we have a clips channel so
um
you need to follow it the link is in the
description um on top of that we have a
are we members only chat today
i believe so yeah yeah we're members
only chat so there's three tiers of the
memberships there's a five dollar tier
the 10 tier at the 10 tier you get to
have access to our exclusive
behind-the-scenes vlogs there's actually
a video of me rapping coming out so if
you guys want to see me rap
10 10 tier um
on top of that guys don't forget to
follow my instagram just.purlythings
and we are going to do a 250k um 24-hour
livestream unfortunately so if you want
yeah so if you want to see us be
tortured for 24 hours straight
subscribe on top of that um some things
that we are saving money for is a bigger
studio i'm in the bigger studio we want
to do some fun things like a dating show
with contestants we want to do like
smash or pass like fun fun stuff but we
need a bigger space so sign up for the
memberships because that gives us a
consistent form of income that we can
count on every single month
that would be on a second channel though
not this channel um just to clarify red
pill here but
today i have a lovely panel so why don't
we go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact starting with you so i'm amber i'm
37 very much single
and a fun fact about me
is
i don't actually have any fun facts i'm
just i'm just fun in general okay
go ahead
hi i'm nelly i'm 33
extremely single
um a fun fact
[Music]
hmm
do you have a pet
i've got two pets
two cats okay
yeah they're great spend a lot of time
with them i mean i wouldn't say it's
really fun but
i don't think i'm like the funniest
person i'm actually quite serious
but
okay go ahead hi i'm francesca i'm 29
years old and
i'm single af and the fun fact is how
i'm still single
that's what's funny about me okay go
ahead hi my name's linda i'm 31
my status
it's really weird and complicated right
now
um
fun fact about me
i was in a kleenex commercial in 2010
that's it you're in kleenex commercial
yeah oh that's lit
um i'm 24 i'm taken
happily taken and
fun fact about me
i'm currently doing some extra work on a
netflix shop listen
right hi
my name is brian
i'm 31
currently
i'm obviously not single
and um fun fact is i'm a rapper
that's it
yes do you want to do alex since you
have a camera there now yeah it makes
sense yeah
alex here you go
uh name's alex can look at the camera
there look at the camera there
yeah there you go
[Laughter]
name's alex uh london-based single
uh fun thing about me is
i
can speak a bit of chinese online for
two years oh that's cool it's a fun fact
okay so
today we are talking about
alpha widows
now i want to know does anyone here know
what an alpha widow is let's let's ask
the girls first
i literally have never heard of this
terminology okay um so i'm guessing it's
something to do with
super strong women but that's as far as
i'll take it okay what about you guys
yeah no i've not actually heard of that
at all
i have no clue and i'm scared to
discover what it's going to be about
okay
never heard of it
okay what about i know you guys um watch
a little bit in the right place
i know both words i don't know the it
together though
so a woman usually with average sexual
market value who sleeps with a high
sexual market value male the alpha male
who does not wish to have a long-term
relationship with that woman the woman
views the alpha male as superior to most
if not all of the other men pursuing her
and so the woman continues to lust after
the alpha male she cannot have
sacrificing future long-term
relationships with lower smv men making
her a widow in a sense
to the original alpha male
wow i feel like so many women are
probably that
that's a fact
yeah
does that resonate with any of you i
feel targeted
[Laughter]
why is there is there like an is there
an x you that you haven't gotten over do
you think about a lot
not to put you on the spot you don't
have to answer if you don't want to not
gotten over but um
that's so weird that is so so weird that
you've actually said that um
i'm actually currently in a situation
where
not in a relationship because i am
single
um
and i feel like i i i say of blocking my
blessings because i'm spending so much
time focused on that person but they
don't want
a relationship as such
would you say that's a common situation
that girls find themselves in
yeah yes yeah would you say like it
doesn't have to be with you but like
with your friends as well
so an interesting stat
um that i learned when i started getting
into like red pill stuff is that 100 of
women want 20 of men so the reason that
women think men are trash is because
we're all sleeping with the same ones
20 is low yeah that's high i think
actually
yeah i mean
if you look at dating app data it's
smaller like some people think it's five
ten percent because okay let's say you
want a guy that's over six foot that's
like a comment i'm not saying you guys
do but that's a common thing that i've
heard of that's only 15 percent of men
or over six foot oh wow so and let's say
you want him to be good looking like
let's say half of people are ugly half
of people are good looking just on that
on average right that's that's 7.5
percent let's say he has to make a
certain amount of money
that's three that's three percent so it
becomes a smaller and smaller percentage
and it's funny because when i tell girls
this stuff
i i see looks of shock but when i tell
men this they're like oh we ben knew
this yeah
it's a fact girls really think that
they can all bag that same guy but
it's just such a small percentage of men
so it's not really it's not logical to
even think like that it's quite
unrealistic exactly
so fairy tale
so i have i have a story
okay so
man's dying wife
asks me to laugh so bad man's dying wife
asks if she can have sex with her ex
just one last time
any spouse would want to provide the
love and care for their partner within
their dying months and days
but one man has shared how his dying
wife has ex has expressed a specific
wish to sleep with an ex posting to the
relationship advice subreddit the
husband gave insight into his wife's
condition and how the conversation of
her controversial dying wish went down
as he has no one i can tell to begin
with he explained how he was destroyed
that his wife of 10 years had a terminal
disease and expected to live at least
nine months i i don't remember life
without her and i don't know what i'm
going to do when she's gone i have been
doing my best to make the last days of
her life good and grant whatever wish i
can he said
on her deteriorating condition he added
the doctor said that she was likely to
need a wheelchair and need a wheelchair
in four or five months and by month
eight she'll be bedridden for the last
few weeks that's if she doesn't decline
faster
after he provided the contacts the
husband got to the quirks of the problem
he said recently she sat me down and
told me that one of the last things she
wanted to do was have sex with a
previous partner of hers
i of course was shocked and when i asked
why the f she wants that her response
was pretty brutal as she revealed
she basically
so basically she thinks that her most
physically compatible sexual lover was
him she gave him a whole monologue about
how sex sometimes is just physical and
how emotionally fulfilling sex is with
me but it was [ __ ] to get to the
point so now i'm left with deny my my
dying wife a wish for my own ego or let
her go [ __ ] another man that she feels
was better honestly i'm so pissed off
and betrayed that she asked this of me i
feel like i'm put in a position where i
have to say yes because she's dying i
don't know what to say but i don't know
if that's right i'm so hurt by that sex
with an ex was apparently so good that
she needed to do it once before she dies
i hate everything about this i'm not
sure what to do
after explaining the situation the
husband's post was met with a lot of
responses some took the story to twitter
where people began to share their
thoughts and where people were divided
there's no division you know divorced
on her deathbed
how long she got to live like nine
months
you're spending nine months alone hello
the last nine months you're by yourself
alone yeah but you you've also got to
kind of figure out like what's happening
you've got to figure out what type of
man that is a man that has gone into a
situation knowing full well he probably
wasn't the number one choice but he
is probably catering to all her needs so
her feeling comfortable enough to have
that conversation with him is a kind of
reflection on their relationship
she don't respect him from jumping yeah
yeah and so for her to have come up to
him and gone yeah look
the sex with you ain't it i'm trying to
find out from the guy i really wanted
you cool with her
that's mad yeah
he probably offered a better package
so he was like that husband material and
obviously you have to make sacrifices at
times and maybe she sacrificed the sex
to have
the perfect relationship the the maybe
the financial support maybe the
emotional support because we all know
sometimes when it comes down to sex it
can be great but the person's not that
good yeah like as a person so maybe that
was why she was with him and you know
one last
goodbye nah man you can't pick and
choose you can't in it she's sacrificed
if she's asking for it in the last nine
months of life so what have i got to do
with you you know why i got a deal with
you that it is but then you wouldn't you
wouldn't like the whole package and then
the last nine months she wants to
[ __ ] die but then can i play devil's
advocate what if we can just say like
sex is just physical right i know we're
going to talk about like intimacy and
emotional and for men it's just physical
if you let me if you're letting me
before these nine months you do me do my
thing
you got a nine-month score on then
but you're not gonna let me do my thing
so it's like
it's different in it for men for men
it's just physical but that's where men
can just soldier on though
well
why are you shaking your head
for men it's it's like not emotional
it's just physical
women can be exactly the same i have
been in that person i have been that
person where i have gone and done what i
felt like i needed to do and had no
emotional connection i just wanted to
have that one experience or
wouldn't you say by and large though
women are attached more emotion to sex
because we release a hormone that men
don't during sex yeah so there's like a
bonding hormone and it's the more
partners you sleep with the less you
release that hormone so a lot of times
like when girls say that it's like
they they had a lot of partners so they
don't release the hormone as much
anymore yeah that's probably where i'm
at
wow oh you didn't know that that makes
so much sense
yeah
particularly like very
i don't like have loads of sexual
partners so i'm really careful because i
know i can get emotionally attached so i
prefer to do it in a relationship or get
pissed off if i'm
in a situationship it's happening it's
not worked out so that makes so much
sense i didn't know that well and that's
why like um
a lot of times they say a girl can't
fall in love unless she's had the best
sex of her life because it's like that's
how girls bond is like
when they that makes sense yeah when
they orgasm yeah so it's like
it's different but men on the other hand
they can have sex with a hole in the
wall and they'll be fine
no no i feel like a lot of men i mean
exactly
majority of men like i've asked this
question like have you ever slept with a
girl that you wouldn't be seen in public
with a hundred percent all men have done
that yeah
ninety nine percent of men have done
that but that's kind of the problem with
the sexual marketplace because
essentially like the small percentage of
men are sleeping with all the girls and
so then like girls think they're on that
level but they're not yeah because like
your level is what you can get to take
you out in public basically okay yeah
that's a fact
there's a lot of girls men wouldn't be
seen with that they've [ __ ] oh can i
say that wait no you
that men wouldn't be seen within public
that they've had sexual relations with
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's similar to
when you have a date you have a blind
date and he turns up and you're like oh
yeah
i can't go anywhere that i was planning
on going and now i need to hide yeah so
it's it works both ways but maybe the
sex doesn't happen that's a bit
different
and you'll get the food and you're going
to [ __ ] off and not see that guy
that guy's suffering let me say that
this whole situation is kind of
unfortunate
because i think i've i've actually been
that person
so there was like um i did this like
american girl she was cali like light
blue hair
really into like every sexual thing you
could imagine was there's like left
crazy liberals you can identify as like
a man
but was is heterosexual but
also as a lesbian she had all the tags
and we were messing around and one of
her her last guy was like
when we hung out she really liked this
guy like she really cherished the
friendship and she tells me that yeah we
spent the night together and it was
trash like like the d was trash
but like the love between them like she
really cherishes this guy um so
yeah and i was there like i mean you
know
the provider
it's unfortunate i just think i find it
really bizarre that a woman or a man can
have sex with someone that they're
i don't know not attracted to like that
or
they don't feel something for
i find that really bizarre well it's
it's because it's gotta have con there's
gotta be connection if i've got no
connection with you
there's no way it's gonna work
it's just right but we were thinking
from a woman's point of view yeah so
from from like the typical woman's point
of view like we're thinking how on earth
could you have sex with someone like
guys will have sex with girls they hate
yeah yeah
you know what it is though
i can't speak for every guy but it's
that it's that post you know i don't
know what's what's yeah but exactly post
not clarity
listen i'm not gonna lie like oh [ __ ]
i spoke to like the man them and and
i've asked them
like questions like that like have you
ever i don't know a lot of guys do is
after the mission complete yeah
they're like
i should have about this mission
beforehand but you don't see that
reality until
like only a very disciplined and aware
man and very like yeah it's not the i'll
feel that majority can definitely sleep
with someone and not feel nothing for
them you know i ain't here for a
relationship is that
yeah i have a lot mates that say
oh yeah i slept with this girl but
i don't faint here i don't i don't i
don't like her and i'm like what
why why did you sleep with her in the
first place
like there is no way why'd she sleep
with him you know because most girls you
kind of know what a guy's after like a
lot of times girls we pretend we don't
know we kind of like
act like because we want the attention
from the guy but we know we know which
guys actually like us and which ones are
just oh yeah we're just pretending we
sometimes say no i don't know then yeah
but yeah as a woman you you already know
you already know if it's gonna be a
prick or not yeah straight away yeah
but but it's crazy though because a lot
of times the same girls will cry later
and say men are trash but how can you
say men are trash when you picked them
yeah yeah you be yourself whatever you
say
don't cry now no
i don't agree with that you don't no why
not though
because
men lie yeah
people aren't clear
people aren't fully honest yeah right so
someone will tell you everything you
want to hear in order to get what they
want 100 right
and then when they get what they want
they might think oh you know what i like
that i want that again
i'm going to keep lying
they're going to get that again
so now the female is sitting there
thinking oh this guy's amazing
but it's all based on a lie
i've i've found more that get what girls
will do is the guy will be broad
and say oh i'm i'm looking you know he
might not say specifically what he's
looking for but if you say are you
looking for a relationship
specifically like they they usually tell
you the truth yeah yeah yes or no
like
no they might say no i'm not cool no and
i don't think they do
i think there's a good 20 of people that
lie
the right guys the right guys a scumbag
will not i don't want to say that about
a guy that doesn't get a lot of girls
will do i don't think it's just that dog
or a guy that's not confident in himself
we'll tell you what you want to hear but
a guy that knows what he
wants tell you exactly
do you know what it is i feel like guys
like because it's so easy a guy that
knows what he wants will just tell you
like
the kind of guy i am if i wasn't with my
girl knows this as well
i don't beat around the bush if i'm
trying to [ __ ] a girl i'll just let you
know straight up listen i'm trying to
hit what are you saying and if it's not
that and to get out it's not just a
random girl either it's a girl that i
would have interacted with before
obviously you don't just go to a random
girl i'm trying to hit what you're
saying but you'll get hit yeah this is
what i'm saying more time you have to
just be open and just i don't want to
waste less time i wouldn't waste no
one's time i wouldn't want someone
wasting my time either so if that's the
direction i'm trying to go with that
girl i'll let it know i'll let it be
known from the start i'm not trying to
waste my time or your time now where are
we going with this that's a good thing
but i mean vice versa if i'm looking for
a relationship would be the same thing
as well yeah i'll let you know from the
job
not everyone is like that's not that way
though
okay i'm curious guys point of view do
you feel like most girls when they pick
a toxic guy they know from the jump he's
trouble yeah like like maybe maybe he
might lie but like they can't girls can
smell other girls
around him yeah i won't say necessarily
other girls yeah but it's like it's like
i feel like
i feel like let's be real yeah like
people know
to an extent you should know when you're
being lied to it depends for example
like a guy can say i love you
this guy don't take you on dates you
don't give you flowers you don't do this
you should kind of know you're not ready
there's no like you can say whatever
words you want yeah and but let's be
real he's not showing it so it's like so
i feel like i get that you know what
because i've got mandom yet and i speak
to them and i'm like
like me personally i've never me i've
only been into relationships so
yeah i don't do relationships unless i
really want to dedicate my time and
stuff but i've asked my guys and i said
like why do you like to
i'm seeing you chat to this girl you're
misleading the wider and he's like bro
she wants to hear this yeah so sometimes
it's like i'll be sometimes you want to
hear these lies because it's like girls
will say that sometimes i don't want to
sleep with someone unless i'm in a
relationship so you don't feel like a
[ __ ] or whatever word but then it's like
this is a fake relationship this is just
for your peace of mind so you want to
hear these lies so you can tell yourself
i was in that relationship i know it too
i feel like sometimes girls say that
though just for the sake of saying it
like you're saying we want to hear
certain things and obviously if your
behavior doesn't reflect that as in like
you were saying you know you're not
taken out you're not showing off you
haven't met any friends or anything like
that like we do the same thing
well some women do i'm one of those
women but to be honest from the get-go
is the best thing
everyone does need a little ego boost
and also we all do want to be charmed a
little bit like you said if you just
walked up to someone and said i'm just
trying to hit that
yeah
it might work but very rarely yeah
there's a small amount of
certain kind of guy that can get away
with that yeah
and you know what i mean it's not
everyone yeah so i think people might
not like it but i think they'll respect
it yeah well the honesty yeah oh yeah
i i feel like honesty is the best policy
i'm just saying i feel like obviously
people lie because
sometimes people want to hear like i
said some people generally one exactly
is so much less be real it is easier to
lie at times but then it's like if
you're a good person that's why you
don't like you know what i mean because
you like you feel morally wrong but is
it easier to lie yes it definitely is
that's why some people just like yo she
knows i don't like her
but let me lie to her
it's easier to tell the truth i got a
question definitely though for you
you know the guy that sorry
you know the guy that um you're in a
situation with did he lie to you about
where you're at
yeah
and when at what point did you figure
out it was a lie
you don't have to answer if you don't
know i'm gonna be very honest because i
do feel like
we all have to take accountability for
our own actions do you see what i mean
yeah um
quite early on probably six months in
okay and how long has it been
two years all right
and you still like maddie in love or not
maddie i don't know like you still
got feelings for him
yeah
that's honest
i appreciate that yeah
what makes you stay you just feel like
you can't walk away
um
or do you do you think at some point
he'll change his mind
i think i did think that
i definitely think i was maybe living in
a bit of hope
maybe there's like a bit of a carrot
being dangled in front of me
you know when i was realizing or when i
was questioning certain things
and
i think i'm probably in a better place
now because i'm quite aware of what the
situation is
and i'm quite ready to just kind of you
know like move forward which is great
um
i can't knock him completely because i
feel like there was a lot of things he
showed me you know how we're talking
about actions speak louder than words
and i think some women will
ignore that
because it's not what they want to see
it's not what they want to feel
you know they want to believe like nah
this guy's right for them
um but in reality if someone is showing
you something yeah you've really got to
take that in
so um how old did you say you are 33 33.
do you ever worry like do you want a
family and like kids and stuff i've got
a son okay he's 14. okay um
i would want to have another child
however i do feel like i'm on a
short time frame now yeah well because i
would just think um
because i i've like broken up with
people or like ended things because
i don't want to waste time and because
you only have so much youth you know do
you ever worry you can't find someone
else because you're still emotionally
invested in this guy absolutely
yeah i feel like i've probably done that
for quite a while yeah
so i definitely think that um
i call it blocking my blessings
you know
if you're emotionally invested in
someone else
then you might miss
someone amazing because
you're mentally still there do you know
what i mean um
yeah i think it's just i think women
generally speaking i think there's a lot
of us that do need to
really take in
what's put in front of us
so and this is a common like complaint i
hear from guys because like they value
you know purity and they value youth
right
and so like a common complaint is okay
you passed over me in your 20s in your
early 30s and now you're expecting me to
come in at 35 and deal with all the
damage that the previous guys have done
for the past decade
and it's it's funny because everyone's
like nodding they're like yeah that
happens
then do you so do you feel like that's
for men an unfair deal yes yeah i do wow
that's bigger you to say it's not fair
because i don't believe they should have
to deal with anyone's past trauma yeah
that's been caused by someone else
i think it's amazing if you do meet a
man that wants to be understanding to
that level where they want to try and
fix that or help you to heal
but i definitely don't think it's fair
that women
put their past trauma onto someone new
that they meet someone that comes into
their life that hasn't done nothing to
them they might that man might be
amazing it might be great you know but
because we've experienced
bad experiences and we've got that
trauma and that bit of scarring
we project that onto them
that's because you haven't healed yeah
because you haven't taken that self that
time for yourself to focus and heal and
deal with over whatever your problems
were or your insecurities and then you
just hand it on to the next person and
obviously nobody's going to handle that
well so so what is healing to you
because i always hear this and i don't i
don't think you can
like you
they say the average person falls in
love three times in their lifetime
so you only get so many chances at love
yeah
and it's like i don't think anyone fully
heals
no i think when i when i refer to the
term as healing i'm i'm like take
yourself back
look at the situation look at the
mistakes you may have made yourself
look at the things you allowed to happen
that might have hurt you
um and and vice versa what the things
that you may have done to that partner
in order for them to behave in a certain
way that you've then felt again was
targeted so i think when i say healing
i'm take yourself back
take some time out you know just focus
on your health focus on your mental
well-being
and do whatever it takes whether it's
meditation whether it's a holiday
whether it's reading books like learning
a new skill
that to me is healing so when i've
healed myself in the past i haven't
gone to
a therapist on a telephone that i don't
know and i'm not saying that that's not
the right thing to do or that it's the
wrong thing to do but for me i just took
time out i stopped dating
i
separated anyone from my life that maybe
i felt was putting me in a predicament
or making me behave or act a certain way
and just focused on me and then
eventually you come back to yourself and
so
again a common complaint that i hear
from guys that it's funny because as a
girl like i know exactly what you're
saying but a lot of times when guys hear
this that sounds like nonsense yeah
and it's because there's no tangible
result
like there's nothing that you can
measure and say that you did it's just
like okay you went on a vacation i don't
know and you thought about what you did
wrong and you're gonna do it better like
how do they know you're gonna do it
better in the future yeah you don't
really need that action stuff yeah yeah
i'm thinking about the other end like
what what have you achieved after that
yeah like when i say a vacation i'm
talking six months somewhere
i'm not talking a holiday to ibiza for
seven days with the girls and hey i'm
over you yeah like i'm talking like
somewhere where you really really take
yourself out of your current lifestyle
your daily routine and then you can
evaluate and obviously there is no time
on healing healing
probably takes years
you never get over everything
but healing to a point then you don't
transfer it onto the next relationship
but i don't think you can not transfer
things to another you can
if you take enough time i feel like you
can you can but there's always going to
be things that may trigger you and it's
up to you
i don't i i genuinely think that there's
some things that your partner might do
that will
prompt a random response
basically yeah like you didn't even know
that you had and that's the moment you
you take a step back and you're like
okay i haven't dealt with this i'm gonna
revisit that but also take the time and
be courteous enough to inform your
partner like hey listen if you guys
haven't had that conversation
this is what i dealt with please bear
with me
it will not happen again if you see it
does let me know feel comfortable to let
me know
so i i really think that healing is
something that can take place also in a
relationship but you have had to have
done the bulk of the work for yourself
do you think that healing needs to have
therapy so there's some tangible result
because it's like if you're just talking
to your friends like they're more likely
to tell you what you want to hear
where a therapist will like sit you down
and tell you about yourself
and i'm currently doing therapy right
now and at first i was just like
this is like what white people do like
no literally because no no literally
this is this is literally my thought
process and even all the people around
me when i finally told them i'm gonna do
therapy they're like were you doing
therapy for that's like white people
stuff it completely changed my life like
completely the first thing i realized
was there's a lot of internal dialogue
that i have going on
in myself and i have an expectation that
the people who are closest to me should
be able to gauge accurately how i feel
because i intuitively am able to
like
know when something is wrong with the
people who are closest to me so i always
felt that there wasn't a balance of
scales let's say
so having that conversation it's not
just about oh how do you feel they've
really untangled the mental mess that's
in your mind and lay everything straight
in front of you to allow you to deal
with it so it's a life skill that you
can take anywhere the workplace
friendships
like so yeah
they start from the beginning someone
said women tend to use words to
grandiose their predicament toxic
healing trauma
as i was going to say so when you were
saying that you kind of um
you know this healing thing and going on
vocation vacation etc to my mind from my
experience because because i've been
with women who are kind of healing
[Laughter]
and it just seems to me that they're
they're waiting for an emotional
stimulus that has you know a greater
impact than their previous guy yeah so
it's true so women want to sleep up no
no one heals and gets with like a really
nice guy who treated their lives she
gets with like a child in thailand and
then she's like oh [ __ ] the last guy you
know i can do better i'm empowered
then she comes back and you know even
the therapy thing i've met a lot of
crazy women who do therapy and most of
the time when they tell me about their
thoughts and what they think in therapy
i just get a lot of feminist rhetoric i
i get a lot of like
using these words and this that to kind
of say things are actually quite simple
that it's like
why do you expect people to know what
you think though because people well
some women like to be like to present
themselves as complex and deep
and especially when they're on their
healing journey they want to come across
us oh i've done the work i'm now work
i'm very aware of myself
but then their actions don't reflect
what it is that they're saying to me
someone who is healing is someone who i
think like you said amber has actually
taken time out so i'm going to be really
quick
november or december last year i cut
someone who was completely toxic off not
only did i cut him off i cut 98 of
people off and i'm talking extended
family like no one knew where linda was
people on my social media if they see
this they'll be like yeah she
disappeared like it's only june that i
came back and even when before that even
when men were approaching me i would
tell them point blank i have gone
through something very like traumatizing
i need
a time like to just deal with myself and
you're someone else's son i'm not gonna
put that on to you and
98 of them was like well that's really
honest i respect you for that and some
sort of basic friendship or connection
was maintained not every day but like on
my socials you know what i mean okay i
can see your facial expressions you're
like what are you talking about but i'm
very like i know what i'm saying okay
but so
cutting off 98 percent of people you say
yeah do you think do you think that's
like healthy especially it was healthy
for me because i'm a giver so because
i'm constantly someone who i used to
have a thing of
if someone did something i'd be like
but how do they feel if i react and pull
myself away from them rather than being
like no what you did something wrong i
love me enough to take a step back and
cut you off because you're now no longer
entitled to my presence so a lot of
people yeah my presence because i know
what i offer in every friendship in
every relationship in every dynamic so i
had to realize that i need to take back
my energy
and just do me and it was the best thing
that i did for six months i've never
been so selfish in my life
i think so you healed by being selfish
yes because i'm a selfless person
like don't you
that kind of sounds like it would have
the opposite effect because because
you'd go to the next guy and say the
last six months i've been selfish date
me no that's not it because
i'm telling you i'm telling you how this
sounds to me
what did you do in your six months i did
indoor rock climbing i went swimming i
painted i started a novel i started i
did things for me so it's funny andrew
tate talks about this how women will
talk like they're the men they want to
date so like if we wanted to date a guy
those are things that like we'd want to
hear about and to hear that he'd done
but like the guys don't care about that
i wouldn't bring up unless they asked
okay
but don't you think so for example right
so when i hear about that journey
um you said like the therapist made you
more accountable right that was like my
first therapist so i chose to do that
yeah okay
but surely if you characterize 98 of
your relationships are so toxic that
they're worthy of being cut off at you
know some some short notice
um because you are a giver which in my
mind sounds like
you lack the self control to adequately
manage healthy boundaries then you know
i'm not being rude but that doesn't
sound as much
accountability as a very complex way
of
digging yourself up but that's part of
the journey not everyone's going to get
it
at that point so it took me two years
and a few more situations to realize
linda you got a poor issue with
boundaries
you are not gonna if someone comes and
tells you you have an issue
or if a girl calls you about the same
issue and you get tired of her telling
you about the same issue you leave her
alone and hopefully if she's self if she
is someone who is self reflective
over time
you hope that that person sits with
themselves until they realize their own
mess and realize i need to change
couldn't you just say stop talking about
this [ __ ]
but that's for that person i can't speak
for them
i'm talking
i'm talking in relation to myself okay i
thought you were saying like you were
tired of listening no no no no no that
was just a random example oh i thought
this was no no
you seem like you have something else to
say i'm just i'm just curious as to why
what are the new relationships if you
built kind of have you somewhat replaced
a portion of that 98
so with the people that left there were
people that also remained and these were
people who would like once a month linda
i know you're taking time up for
yourself i respect your your thing what
you're doing just letting you know that
i'm i'm sending you love
so once i was ready to go back and
be on socials and be around people
those small group of people i'll say
about 10 to 15 or the people that i kept
really close to me because they
understood my boundaries they understood
what i was doing and interestingly
enough they were all kind of like
working on themselves as well 10 to 15
people yeah that's a lot so so how many
i know you want to go into the 98 yeah
how many was that how many people was
that so that was extended family because
i needed to focus himself people on
social media that i don't know because
there was a lot of things that i used to
do on socials people hit me up in the
dms and it was too overwhelming for me
on twitter and on instagram and i was
like i can't do this i can't deal with
this anymore
so how many people was that
do you want to go and look on my socials
both twitter and instagram then you can
work it out for yourself what did you
used to do
sorry i apologize i need to know okay so
between 20
2012 to 2016 i ran my own publishing
company
produced four magazines glossy titles
everything independently myself and my
partner at the time
left that got into the workforce and
everything and then i've always done
things to do with like podcasting like
i'm here now today
or like filming i used to do actor stuff
like extras like i was in holby city for
a bit like as an extra i've always done
creative things so along the way i've
met tons of people who remember me or
remember my interactions those are the
bulk of the people who are on my socials
and support me or whatever so yeah
so and those are the people that were so
toxic you you cut them off
no i told you about a toxic relationship
last year that i cut off so therefore i
decided to cut off 98 of people okay
there's two different including people
like this why what would be the people
you meet naturally those were the people
on my socials that i felt were quite
overwhelming because i didn't want to
always respond to their dms and at that
point boundaries were a bit shaky for me
okay
sorry
i've got something to say okay
do you just feel like you just wanted
space yes because i felt i couldn't
like i couldn't bloody breathe
yeah i think the short of it is
you just wanted space yeah you wanted
time for you yeah you didn't want to
really be dealing with
a lot of people or be so you had
selective few people that you could deal
with yeah
and other than that you just wanted your
space yeah i think it's more that like
sometimes we just need space like
not every day you want to talk to people
no of course especially from a massive
family not every day you wanna not every
day we wanna be happy sometimes we wanna
get up we're pissed off
did someone say that you can't you can't
fully you said you can't fully heal
right or something along them lens or am
i reaching yeah someone said that cool
no i said sometimes you probably can't
fully heal all right cool so do the
training but there's still tiny little
elements of you that are still gonna
have have you ever mind
i'm guessing most of us have heard that
saying if it's not a blessing it's a
lesson right
cool so for me healing is like when you
can go through a situation and be like
it's not affecting me no more i've
learned it's not like because i get that
what baggage is like for example if
someone broke your trust in a previous
relationship
you're going to move that you might move
that to another relationship but it's
how you move it there's a difference
you're paranoid now
which you didn't get the blessing you
know i mean i mean you didn't get the
lesson out of that or you can be a bit
cautious which is a normal reaction so i
feel like you can heal when it's just
about
how you deal with it how you deal with
it giving it enough time i know enough
people that get out of a toxic
relationship give it a month in another
relationship and you're like what are
you doing you're still dealing with your
problems that's because they don't know
how to
stay single like some people they they
they have these strong needs to be in a
relationship to fulfill that
void that they feel so maybe you can
heal properly just a lot of people don't
do it the right way yeah exactly
i can't articulate why but when i hear
people talk about healing it just sounds
like nonsense
and i can't i can't articulate why do
you know what i get what you mean but i
can't it's so personal but it doesn't do
yeah it's about perception and i get
what you mean though i do it's just like
it just sounds like a huge change like
one person one person was alone for six
months one person went on a trip one
person yeah it's not what you mean i
don't
know from a man's perspective we don't
really care about hearing about no heat
no but it depends though do you like if
you're dealing with someone already they
say they don't know what that's talking
about no but let's say they're going to
hillary
why'd you want to be out here putting
classes on people all the time
i heard that
so
come on because because i'm just like
even if you're you cut off 98 of people
how does that make you a better
girlfriend in six months nothing to do
with a relationship it had everything to
do with me and how i felt for my mental
health well i'm just thinking like from
the guy's point of view
yeah that's not something i'll just run
into a relationship and be like oh so by
the way i'm healing obviously
that's going to scare anybody i'm like
healing from what you'd be surprised
but you know what i just realized men
don't say they're healing i've never
heard a man say we just well that's
because
well no i think i think men like women
kind of dramatize things like i think
we're kind of more dramatic like it's a
bit dramatic to cut off 98 of people for
six months it went for me yeah i mean
i'm not saying i don't i don't i don't
know you i don't know what's but i'm
just saying like men are like okay i
took that out i'm gonna move on yeah
yeah
girls or girls
they'll either go and say oh i had a to
heal in my whole face or i had to heal
and cut everybody off or i had to heal
like this this ninety percent of the
time i do feel like healing is an excuse
or a cover-up for i'm about to go wild
right now which is i mean like that's
what jada that's what jada pink is women
yeah
i mean
i mean what did what did jada say on on
the red table talk she said it's a
season of healing and that's like the
like that sounds nuts
and what did she do she she screwed uh
her daughter's drug addict friends yeah
and she said she was healing him
my healing can be different to
everyone's healing yeah that's
that's like confusing because a lot of
times girls will use words and like we
can't even agree on what they mean yeah
so it just kind of comes off as like
nonsense to men but it doesn't matter
it matters to you and it makes sense to
you but what i'm saying when you're
communicating to other people it does
matter that they can understand you
yeah you need to continue
to be understood there's that but i
think we need to it's both ways though i
feel like like if you want to let's say
you're only healing to not actual not
only your healing aid to better yourself
as an individual and be to then be ready
for another relationship because be
around others yeah exactly so
yeah i get like in that aspect then it
of like yeah that's nothing to do yeah
but it's just it's just when we say
healing a lot of times there's no
nothing tangible that anyone could say
you're a better person now than you were
six months ago it's just like oh some
time has passed i didn't talk to people
or oh i went on a vacation or oh i went
i wrote the see what are they called
i would disagree too yes sir
i
um was in a relationship for quite some
time anyway it didn't work out as these
things sometimes do
and i got really angry and i got really
aggressive at this person and i was
heartbroken and then i had to take a
while for myself to realize
actually a lot of that the red flags
were there but i still sat back and let
things ride and what have you and a big
part of healing if you want to say that
you know for me was celibacy
yeah and i've been celibate for two and
a half years
and anyone that comes to me
the first thing i say is my name's amber
if you're trying to get my number
because you think you're gonna [ __ ] me
just know i'm celibate and i've been in
this for two and a half years
so i'm happy to exchange numbers i'm
happy to maybe be your friend but if you
think you're getting anything else out
of me right now i still don't
think i'm ready to offer that to you so
you know celibacy for me was a massive
thing do you think that's going to make
it difficult for you to find a partner
um saying that you're celibate because i
think guys typically and i'm not looking
for a partner okay that was going to be
my next question do you do you want to
be married do you want to like have a
partner okay so if that's that approach
you're married and children are not for
me would you would you want like a
long-term boyfriend or something um i
had
long-term boyfriends in my 20s i'm now
in my late 30s obviously you know there
is no better feeling than being in love
that is an emotion we cannot control and
we don't know how we're going to act you
know the idea of being in love again yes
it would be nice however i'm in
absolutely no hurry to get into that and
when i feel like i'm ready and when i
feel like i'm comfortable to let that
run then i'll let that run
so do you ever feel like um like
maybe you might run out of time at some
point no
do you
do you feel like because 50 of a woman's
options are gone by 30 if you're trying
to have children yeah no no it's just um
on which men find you attractive
typically and i i'm just saying at some
point like
men aren't lining up to date 70 year old
women right now so so at some point time
runs out yeah we don't i don't i can't
say what age that is and it differs like
depending on the person yeah right but
like a lot of times what i've heard from
guys is they'll come in and they're like
oh she's making me wait but the last guy
got it for free yeah so it's frustrating
that you should the whole making people
wait thing
i don't i don't agree with that i think
if you feel it and you want it go for it
as simple as that like that's that's
what chemistry is and if you have that
in that immediate connection with
someone and you want to do things then
do it why are you waiting okay i didn't
know if that's what you were doing like
because you said guys okay okay i
misunderstood no no there's no waiting
it's more a case of
right now nobody really jumps out
so when i feel a connection then cool
i'm ready for it but
until that i'm not just kind of like i'm
not waiting there's there's no time
limit on
you know we've had a pandemic right so
and i like a lot of people had to move
home so that kind of
you know prolonged the situation but
yeah well it's just more like a lot of
times
you know i wonder why more girls don't
um
approach dating with a sense of urgency
because i hear i hear that a lot with
women like oh i have time whatever but
like
you know how much time do we really have
we only have until tomorrow comes and
sometimes tomorrow isn't guaranteed yeah
so you have to choose to live your life
i i think you choose to live your life
in the moment
i think it depends on the culture as
well because it looks like in the uk we
do things a bit differently but in
america like
the girls that i know i've got a lot of
family in america they're very strategic
with how they date they will date
multiple guys
and
decipher which is the best one and then
go for that i think they've got it
well the ones that i talk to they've got
it they've got some sort of like
regime that works and i think from what
i understand here in the uk
we still well some of us still have this
mentality of let me date one person at
one time and i think that
can cause
time wasting
so i think it's just some i think there
might be cultural differences i think
it's just things that we need to kind of
because it's different everywhere all
over the world like even in italy like
there is uh there are
90 percent of the women there are like
they're such in a rush to settle down
yeah to get married to have kids i got a
lot of girlfriends like in their 20s
married with kids and i'm like what
why you're such a rush it's a cultural
way that yeah should get married before
30s and yeah well 90 of your eggs are
gone by 30. so i mean there is some sort
of like if you want four or five kids
you only have so much time to do it
yeah i mean
and 30 of women experience infertility
issues so if you if you want kids like
your 20s is your best bet
but isn't that also based on genetics as
well because there are some families
where the women's their menopause are
like mid 50s 60s
um yeah like so my mom
like is in her 50s she still hasn't but
and she's had her last kid in her 40s
but
um i think what i've heard is a lot of
like the toxins and stuff are making
women have fertility issues earlier and
plus we've all been on birth control
since we were like 16.
yeah and so it's like
with all this stuff a lot more women are
experiencing experiencing infertility
issues but it's interesting you say all
the women um italy the average age of
first marriage is 34.
that's that's lying
it could be it could be let me put women
let me put women because that could
maybe there's age gap in
oh no 32 that's crazy
so it's i knew it was 31 in the uk it's
actually 27 in the us so it's 31 and
i'll explain to you why okay
go ahead italian men's are like the
eternal peter pans yeah so they're gonna
take ages to settle down because mommy
is still gonna be there cooking for them
and washing the laundry that's why women
are like okay i'll be your fiance for 10
years and when you're gonna be ready to
leave your mommy then we're going to get
married that's why then the averages is
32. do you think maybe it could possibly
be that the women aren't marriageable
because it's just interesting because
whenever i talk to men and women like
women are very quick to put it on the
men yeah but it's never on the woman
oh no it can't yeah it's both sides you
two yeah just both sides like women can
be [ __ ] up as men it's the same way
it's just that like if i need to think
about cultural point of view yeah in
italy like we got a lot
men's that are still
like
very
peter pan's they're children basically
we have those in england
i'm sure they're everywhere yeah but
it's like you know it's this cultural
way that you stay home with your parents
and they leave
like they leave their house like late in
their thirties
while here in uk i can see like
especially in london a lot of people
like young people 20 21 living by
themselves renting the house having this
kind of job and this and this and this
you need to leave like really here i
feel like every person i meet like half
the people yeah half the people i meet
in their 20s live at home yeah really
yeah definitely i do think there's a bit
of a divide though there are some who
well it really depends it's a mixture
but there are quite a lot of people that
do live at home with their best would
you say the same thing for a woman like
she's not growing up if she's living at
home yeah um yes yes
most of the time yeah yes but it's just
interesting because i would say by and
large because women make less money
there's probably more that live at home
with their parents
so it's it's funny that we put it on the
men and we say they don't grow up
because like you know
it goes both ways right yes in italy
women are waiting for that men to earn a
certain amount of money that so you're
gonna provide for me and you're gonna
buy a house and you're gonna do this and
this and this otherwise my parents his
mom until he gets the money sorry so he
has to stay at home with his parents
until he gets the money if you're
expecting all of that yeah
but most most girls can't get that
because it's only like 20 of women get
to stay home and be a housewife if less
and most women aren't willing to do the
age gap which is like the best way if if
you want to do that is to like date a
guy in his 50s
like you're yeah you're you're 20 you're
29 you want to you want to be a
housewife tomorrow find a guy in his 50s
he'll do it yeah
yeah
yeah but most so it's it's almost like i
we have these high standards for men
that a lot of them just can't yeah that
are unrealistic at times you know yeah
we still got the stereotype of amanda
it's going to be the prince charming
that what earth uh his name yeah disney
like saving you giving you that great
life
when i do really think that is
every person as an individual you should
provide for yourself a great life and
then if you're going to find apartment
that's going to suit your galaxy that is
not going to be your planet it's going
to suit your galaxy then great
you don't think it's okay to depend on a
man
no no no no wait wait
really so none of you think it's okay to
depend on a man i disagree i don't mind
depending on a man but i think that's
because of like how i was raised and my
cultural background so i'm from west
africa sierra leone and
like the way everything was done my
parents came in the 80s the way
everything was done my dad did
nearly everything the only thing i
remember my mom paying for was like
the light and the
yeah the electric and she depended on
him but he didn't control her either so
she went to work she did whatever and
they kind there was just a normal
balance and i think that's quite no i
don't know because you're both african
as well i don't know what the setup is
but that's what i saw so i don't have an
issue taking money from a man depending
on a man it doesn't make me any less of
a woman if anything i feel more in my
femininity but that's my own do you feel
like it's a like then if a man's taking
care of all the bills do you feel like
it's reasonable that he gets more
control
yeah of course i'm gonna be the leader
of the ship
someone has to stay i can't stare and
he's staring and he's doing all this
yeah so question do you guys why did you
say no it's not okay to depend on a man
i think for me it's my personal
experience i got divorced parents and i
grew up with my mom being very
independent and providing for us and she
always like tell me
do not let a man pay for your stuff yeah
make sure that you're going to have your
job and everything sorry out because at
the end of the day
something's going to go wrong
you know how to be independent you don't
you're not going to need anyone
so probably in all means like
if i'll be in a relationship i want to
be independent in terms that if
something is gonna like end it i'll
still gonna make sure to you're okay i'm
i'm i'm okay with that do you think
that's maybe hindered you in dating
because part of femininity is
relinquishing control yeah yeah yeah and
and so if we're always taught we can't
count on men men are like okay then why
would we sign up
like because men men want to be needed
yeah yeah they do and so if they don't
feel like they're needed they don't have
purpose yeah that's why i made i had
like a really bad choices in my
relationship because then i
i present myself like the independent
woman strong woman that doesn't need
anything from anyone and then you know
men's are like yeah so what what why am
i here well i'm here like but i i think
you can be both because i'm that very
independent woman
i
work my butt off i've done everything i
needed to do for myself and i'm aware
that i don't need anyone but that's not
to say that i don't want someone to do
those things for me or was it when a guy
approaches you and he's interested in
you but you're not interested in that
guy
it's if i'm not interested in them i'm
not interested
there needs to be no but there needs to
be an attraction first off or you know
something that's intrigued me about you
and then obviously like i said i'm not
shut off to it i'm just celibate right
now yeah like i'm not shut off
and the guy that you're attracted to
comes in the room but he doesn't
approach you what are you going to do
approach him
cool
that is how i've gotten
my guys shouldn't i mean that women
shouldn't rely on men no oh no no no i'm
saying was that a question
i mean it's like this me personally i
feel like it's about what you bring to
the table it's like yeah for example
it's like
you should definitely rely to a man if
you're filling in the gaps but if you
now like for example let's say he's just
focused on money and he's
just solely the provider i feel like you
should be taking care of other areas
because you're already provided for if
you now you want to be at home and rely
on a man he's a pimp he's a simple pimp
simply whatever you want to call it he's
it's not a fair bargain so in that
aspect you shouldn't rely on a man but
you have to listen to something else he
pays every single thing now you
financially you don't worry about a
single thing take care of the house it
needs to be balanced
balance is really really important like
um
doing it wrong i love being independent
i do
everything for myself but
i think there should be fairness like i
ain't hung up my bra
if i was to meet someone and settle down
with that person for example if i was to
get married and have more children and
i'm at home and i'm raising those
children then i'm probably not going to
go out to work
because i'm raising the kids that make
sense so i'm going to do the household
duties and he's going to be the provider
which is fair that's what i think
exactly you know what i'm saying there's
balance
and to solely provide on a man if i'm
not having kids and i'm not doing
anything well
that would kind of make me lazy
he's getting a short end of the stick so
i have a question what do you guys feel
like you could bring to a guy
that he couldn't just hire a maid and a
hooker to do
that's a good i made a cook and a hooker
to do
so basically you need kids kids
kids is the only thing yeah i'm sorry to
interrupt but it's kids yeah because
i feel like you have to match his energy
like if you if you're trying to chase
someone that has got all this drive and
ambition to be the best and they're
putting in the hours at work you also
need to be of a similar
person like you need to have that
similar personality no because men men
and women look for different things so
like men don't care about your money
they don't care about your career they
don't give away no they they don't care
about they don't care about what you do
but i think you still need to do that
for yourself i mean you can do what
makes you happy yeah but it doesn't but
no
that's terrified
sorry you're right you're right actually
you're correct you're correct but i'm
saying like like don't complain about
the results though
so if you want to do what makes you
happy don't complain about the results
yeah so like i mean you can you can you
can like become the guy
but like men don't like guys they're
like women that are like
men like guys no you don't need two
yings
yeah you won't fit together or two yangs
it don't work it's yang again so your
question was what do we bring to the
table yeah
yeah a man who can't get from a maid or
yeah like from a from a maid like
made cook and a hooker a paid service i
was gonna you know some hookers provide
emotional safety and intimacy
companionship there are loads of men
that i talk to that are like
linda do you know what sometimes i think
my partner doesn't understand that i
need someone to talk to i need someone
who i can feel vulnerable to
without her throwing it back in my face
yo all right so
you said
men shouldn't um
they they go to their women or they're
they're worried about we say that again
sorry
so basic wait what
[Laughter]
so
i think what they
yeah the vulnerability they want to
they want their partner to they want to
feel safe to be vulnerable without her
throwing it back in their face when they
have an argument okay so those men
should not be
emotional to their women because it's in
female nature to
if let's say there's an argument between
a man and a woman
if she has ammo there is no line that
she wants she she won't cross
and
men arguing between men there are lines
they understand i cannot respect exactly
i can't speak about his mother otherwise
all wall breakers however if i'm arguing
with a woman
and she goes say sad about my mom and
her cooking and the last time she said
she she came over
there's no boundaries and so the
solution is that men should go and speak
to their male friends
about situations that are
emotional to them that are
deep to them and then once they've come
up with solutions with their male
friends they should go and have the
solutions ready for their woman ish
that's easier said than done because i
agree i actually ran a room on this on
clubhouse about this whole dynamic and
men also said that they don't always
feel safe to speak about really
emotional things because they don't even
know how
because it makes them feel less of a guy
in front of their guy
that's not really your guys that's not
your game but
then my solution to that is if you don't
feel com comfortable having a
conversation with your guy friends then
go to an elder like
this is an encore father figure where
they're not in the same
dynamic or group settings
they've done life they've been there
done that got the t-shirt and that way
you can have a conversation with them
that will allow you to feel that oh even
if i i i can feel less of a man if i'm
talking to a guy that's been there he's
he's done things that i could never
imagine do you know what i'm saying
that's what so what so if a guy doesn't
want to be emotionally vulnerable he
says i got my boys for that what could
you offer him
me personally yeah
i wouldn't lie and say peace of mind
[Laughter]
i said that's a big value for me but but
do you know what yeah i'm learning i
don't mind being like honest yeah i'm
learning that sometimes we just need to
shut up as women
no no no like yeah
honestly like we need to shut up i like
i'm guilty of this because sometimes i
can get so emotional and i'm just like
wait hold on
it's not really that big of a deal let
me just take a step back
and i get more of a positive outcome
when i'm a little bit more logical with
a man that i'm romantically involved
with than when i'm all over the place
and then the second thing is listen
because often times yeah men really are
telling us what the issue is what the
problem is and then we take a we take
like an example
our girls
oh
he's like but you've missed everything i
was trying to say
so peace of mind if we could do that we
could offer that
that a hoe and the other ones can't do
what do you guys think
i do agree with that i think listening
is so important
because they will men will tell you yeah
and more time you don't listen yeah you
just don't because you you want to hear
what you want to hear yeah
what suits you what makes you feel good
you feel me so
we don't listen that's very true i'm not
saying i'm not going to say everyone
because i'm
bombarded but
i think there's a big percentage of
women that don't listen we don't listen
and we talk on top of men as well we
talk over them
as well i think we need to allow men to
be men and women need to be women and i
think
that is something that's so important
there's too many women trying to be they
are trying to be men
that's me what are you
no that's i like you you're not you're
not alone that's like a common um role
of tomasi always says women become the
men they want to marry yeah so they get
good with their finances they get in
shape they do all the things that they
want yeah in a guy would you say yeah
that's what happened to me basically my
my relationship went down in the toilet
because
i was the man
like i wasn't even allowed them to pay
for dinner or offer me a dinner because
i know i'll pay i'll do that you want to
go out on a weekend i'll pay how long
did i last
well the last ones just six months
that's
yeah i know i know now
i went in that healing process yeah
oh [ __ ]
i'm going to make a point on that yeah i
did i didn't went in spain i didn't wear
on a holiday with my girlfriend yeah
i just no i just know where to go
no i i didn't no no i just see here
london and i was like you know what i
think that something's wrong with me
it's not me that like it's not that
other people are
it's
accountability though that's me probably
i'm being a prick as well
so
i should work on myself and being honest
with me accept what are my limits
and what i should ill
might post traumas and
like choose a partner that we can be
both equally like completely 50 and i
need to be able to accept them to help
me when i need that
so i'm trying to i'm working on me i'm
trying to be more a woman yeah that's
great what you just said there as well
working on yourself that is healing
yeah but in a nutshell
oh gosh
yourself i just you're like nothing
stupid
and healing what a different word for it
i think working on your self-healing is
is learning from your mistakes
learning what you made for wearing this
yeah like yeah self-awareness
definitely if you learn though
definitely yeah yeah yeah apply it and
then yourself is just a blanket
statement literally of i'm just doing
whatever so i have the rubbish right
random copy
i have this theory right so
because i've met a couple of women on
this healing journey and
there's there's always a couple of
patterns right firstly there's the whole
like basically they're going for like
more emotionally impactful moments that
normally includes getting with another
chad etc
normally they come back with
a heightened ego so it's more like
normally i hear this it's kind of like
yeah
i shouldn't have they say one thing
negative about themselves and it's
always like a false negative it's always
like i was too loving attention to
details i was too nice i gave too much
stuff like that and then they go on a
list about how everyone else was crap
you know this guy did this that guy was
talking to that but i was also too
loving and it's like it's like their way
of being like oh now countable those
other women you met though well i can
only speak from experience i'm not it's
a theory right it's not i haven't said
it's like you know how the world works
this is how i think about why you
attract these kind of woman yeah
you just do the same thing as describing
no you just don't trust me
that's not a false name i actually own
mine no but you know no but it's like
it's like the false negative is saying
like i'm bad with bound like i it's
funny i always hear this too it's like
girls always say like i'm bad with
boundaries and it's like a way to say
it's everyone else and not me no but
yeah it's you no because because it's me
letting them do what they want
but but that's still yeah it's still a
false like they understand like that
yeah do you know it is i feel like it's
easier to deflect than be accountable in
it it's definitely easier to say oh this
person gets me angry or they do this to
me instead of saying you know what i can
be a bad person at times or i can get
real triggered or i don't exactly so
yeah that's what yeah
i think it's it's
it's normally i think the issues
normally from those the women i've met
two or three who are
very very intelligent you know oxford
cambridge educated who are reasonable in
a lot of ways but i've noticed that that
point they try and make an emotional
situation rational and when they
rationalize it it tends towards
narcissism in my view so i'll finish
that theory right so they come off with
their one thing that's bad with me 10
things that's bad with everyone else
and then normally they
they they come out of that with
heightened expectations from everyone
else except for themselves so they're
normally kind of like
ah you know
i don't have time like you're bad i'm
not dealing with that i've been to
therapy
you know entire woman
i've seen that that's this they've got
they've got all the answers for everyone
else after this healing journey but i've
noticed that they're less feminine now
like they're more into themselves they
tend to use words like i'm doing me now
this is a media which i think is like
not really the point of relationship
like coming out of a bad relationship
more self-focused isn't helping you find
a better relationship it's just making
you
more more narcissistic like you're
you're giving less now self-centered you
know you've just convinced yourself that
you've grown but actually you're giving
less and you're more you're less patient
with people
and you're you're less able to sustain
healthy relationships because you're
more judgmental now using the guise of
therapy and this and that that means
that that's that's how i i i and then
and then that's i've heard this from so
many guys where they're saying like
basically then they'll have these high
standards and all these things they
expect from a guy but it's like you're
making me pay new prices for a used
battered damaged product
and they'll be like or or then they'll
make the next guy wait because of all
the damage they had from before but
there he's like but the last guy didn't
have to wait i won before the one before
that
and i guess like the way guys look at it
is like over a certain age
they just see it as you've let someone
like someone's gotten in for free
yeah but again it comes down to wow
people need to be accountable you're not
free women need to be accountable and
men need to be accountable it's very
clear-cut yeah do you know what i mean
best just to be honest as well
why were you fired from your last job i
worked too hard said no man ever
[Laughter]
i gave
your theories are very well thought out
that's what i think so far
okay guys i'm gonna take a second to
read super chats um
guys all super chats go towards updates
in the studio i appreciate you all so
much for sending super chats because it
really helps us invest in a bigger place
next year i want to get a three four
bedroom i wanna i wanna max out all the
different rooms and make different
studios so we can start channels for
people like auntie and other people that
want to start channels and even do smash
or past dating shows we're going to make
a bunch of different channels in this
house
but we need super chats and we need
memberships especially memberships to
fund it and keep it going on top of that
guys go follow my instagram it's
just.pearlythings i'm trying to get to
30k
followers on instagram so that's really
important we also have a twitch page a
facebook page and also also go follow
i say facebook twitch oh and our new
clips channel yeah yeah so our super
chats i saw a bunch from sentience shout
out to you i'm pulling it up really
quick on my thing okay
so um we got one from ata women want to
submit to a man not a tyrant lifted by
the wind pearl why are women so afraid
to come compromise with men why so
resistant to change joshua
sintran men don't feel safe to be
vulnerable because modern women take
full advantage of that mr negative men
talk about their friends men talk to
their friends they listen emphasis
empathize but don't try to fix it
soja for christ we are at war ladies
that say y'all are independent and don't
need a man one where is that man two you
will never be independent of men society
is built kept running by men three if my
woman told me she didn't need me i would
say there is the door peter quit
peter quinn women from sierra sierra
leone is that they said okay okay um
have have you heard of ishmael bay the
author his memoir was amazing a long way
gone bless your country
the uk economist remember women who are
not traditional cannot expect tradition
a traditional man only a tiny percentage
of women qualify for these men
doug mpa so much misandry feminism freed
up women from having to be barefoot and
pregnant feminism also freed up men from
having to provide for women you ladies
created the world where men don't have
to grow up enjoy it ladies gus
[Laughter]
if um gus if women were more
marriageable more men would step up 90
free tope why is walter
mercardo on the show look him up lol ata
women's hearing women healing sounds
expensive and oh ish
sentience was absent zentian is a normal
super chat everyone clap everyone clap
everyone
kleenex the only reason you haven't
heard men talk about healing is because
the world doesn't care about men's
hardships and issues women expect men to
be the stability in their lives
regardless of what men experience even
to the man's detriment soja boy for
christ we are at war ladies most men
when hearing hearing you were on a
healing journey especially red pill men
assume you were healing through riding
the cc which is like the
the
carousel that
you can okay okay i don't i don't know
what youtube aka sexual healing chris
chris a hundred dollar super chat let's
go
stream sponsor come on come on um did
you know august is jada pinkett smith's
favorite month to celebrate this here is
jada's favorite
here is jada smith's quote it is
important to prioritize i know for me my
family comes first that makes every
decision very easy
right really i don't know
90 free top men resent women who can't
say when enough is enough
mr negative the best way to get over one
is to get under one the uk economist
please
um please ask your guests oh i'm gonna
ask this in a second um the uk economist
i'll come back to that um joshua clinton
healing is a cop out it's a buzz word
for a trip to the jersey shore and avoid
a therapist like the plague
matt butcher highly impressed with the
kleenex model cleaning up her life
ladies listen and learn
tech sprint how do y'all feel about
someone that just plays the consistent
he did this she did this card the x
stories live very deep in my partner
thoughts chris another 100 super chat
come on
notice how the ladies always blame men
not taking any accountability and fight
back against professional therapy they
focus on things outside of themselves
because the focus in the mirror is too
painful sentience again why do guys lie
although most men of value will be
brutally honest just reflect on the fact
that the top 20 of men are the ones
passing around the majority of women so
when you want to pre reproduce the
bottom 80 percent of men do what they
can to get it um
smay's um
sammy taken
i said my mic just got
okay it's still going um sentience to
the kleenex women if sex is just
physical
i can't hear it again
yeah yeah oh no i can't okay to the
kleenex women if sex is just physical
then why did the woman leech off her
husband for years only to show her true
colors by demolishing her husband's
prides feelings and trust by asking for
that illicit death wish
vincent delisal jr if my wife ever had
the audacity to dis disrespect me by
asking to sleep with her ex one last
time i'd have the audacity to pull that
troll
jerome barum denver colorado 39 years
old 120 k in net worth in the medical
field credit eight twenty five nine bmi
twenty percent homeowner i don't want a
leftover woman for a life partner how
would you suggest that i found a more
pure woman um
what would i say i mean it's hard these
days but i will say
see i want to say churches like certain
churches but then like you also get the
opposite in church
yeah so um
i don't know i i've always found that
like girls that have hobbies and are um
more like doing things
um don't do as much like partying i
think it's better to go for girls that
aren't super big partiers i guess yeah
that's that's what i would say yeah i
think men get so used to the game that
you start to like toxic or not toxic
women about women who play games
and you notice that after after a while
dating you meet a nice pure decent girl
and you're like she's a bit too simple
though yeah yeah i need some trouble i
wonder
a bigger compromise between like that
bad bad bee in the club you know and a
sweet one yeah yeah
yeah it's that saying like good guys
never win
it's the same thing like we want the
good guys the winners are so much more
attracted to the bad guys like in the
end yeah they always win because you end
up compromising on what you initially
wanted
i don't know i think i don't think they
win because they get the leftover women
like it's like it's like you can't you
can't say you win when you get that like
when you get the women at less value
yeah it's not fun i don't enjoy that
like but i'm going to be less valuable
in 10 years but it's just true i'm
settling yeah because you're the last
one left yeah but you might not be the
last one left because you might have
they might have been working towards and
then they're just they're there you are
what do you mean like they might have
been working towards their careers and
then all of a sudden they're like now
i'm ready and then it's you know picking
up from what is well i think but i think
the issue is i mean typically like if
guys accomplish are accomplished in
their career they date younger women
yeah so so it's like but a lot of times
a complaint i hear is like even though
they might have met that girl later like
they know she would have rejected them
in her 20s yeah and so it's the same
concept as like the alpha widow because
the whole concept is she really wants
the guys from her 20s she's just
settling and in her head even though
that's not settling it's just her level
yeah
um
okay let's see the count 25 i alpha
widow women all the time they come back
all the time after you dump them it's
sad really dj be fit when a woman says
she's going through healing she's
resetting her life that's a red flag my
question is how many times how how many
times these girls took to heal
okay so the uk economist had a question
i just want to find it okay
would you
if you guys had daughters um i know you
said you have a son i don't care
daughter but if you did have a daughter
would you tell your daughters to be
virgins until they're married so they
can avoid toxic men and drama
hell no i don't think you can tell your
children to be virgins they're going to
do what they want to do
right but regardless of what you tell
them is going to benefit them later in
life so so i i would say but as as
parents you have a lot of influence
so i mean you can't control them yeah
but like like my dad is someone i listen
to a lot so if i ever have like a
business decision and i can't decide one
way or the other i often go to my dad
and i take his advice a lot so if you
were in a position where you did have
maybe not control but a lot of influence
is that what you would say no i would
tell my daughter to wait okay um
because there's a big age gap between me
and my brother and i taught him like the
importance and the spiritual aspect of
sex and that
allowed him to keep his virginity to for
quite a long time and he was actually
like you know what i'm glad i waited so
if i can have that influence on my
brother
why wouldn't i tell my daughter to wait
and i'm not just going to be like
wait
because of the social implications of
well what we call you know sleeping
around and all of that i'm going to tell
her about the emotional aspect with it
you know the physical aspect what it
does to your body if you start having
sex too early too young how men view you
so they have a more holistic kind of
perspective because oftentimes when we
as young people are more informed
we can make better decisions sometimes
parents use abstain or be celiba as a
scare tactic and it's usually because of
pregnancy
that's what i think okay what do you
guys think i think that
like having sex in a relationship is an
important step to understand a lot of
things
even like as an individual as a person
if i have a daughter i want her to feel
free to having a open conversation with
me of course i will advise to her to
wait until now 18 years old to be more
aware
but at the same time i will say to her
be responsible on your choices like
protect sex
yeah but
if if for you it feels natural i want
you to be yourself
and to experience that
do you think that that could possibly
leave your daughter open to predatory
men
because when you're 18 you don't have
the life experience to really know the
difference
and so if you're saying like do what
feels natural like the guys that make
things feel natural have studied women
if you have a really good first date
he's practiced men men are like
naturally
we're very confusing a guy has to
practice to understand us
yeah but at the same time you
you educate
your your daughter to be like
independent and smart and like clever
and you like as a parent you you don't
know if you you your work is good and
but at least i think you as a mom you
can say at least you're trying to give
to your son what do you think is right
and then it's going to be up to him or
up to her to make the best decision for
her because at the end of the day is an
independent person
i can try my best but i will never gonna
control your actions right but i'm not
talking about control i'm talking about
influence because i'm with you i think
like kids need to make their own
decisions to some extent because they
can't get to a certain age and have
never made a decision for themselves
right but at the same time it's like as
a parent if you have a good relationship
with your kid you have a lot of
influence yeah of course and i i just
i'm not sure that saying to do it when
it feels natural is great it feels
natural in terms that if in that moment
i i don't know probably your first
boyfriend your experience and for you it
feels natural to have that first time
with that person that you really feel
into into deep just
enjoy and embrace that moment that's
what i'm saying don't say yeah go live
i just if i had like a kid i would just
say be careful because i there's only so
many times you can fall in love yeah and
like and every every time you i i think
every time you get your heart broken you
can't fall in love as deep with the next
person
and you only have so much oxytocin you
can give to guys and so if you really
want to feel bonded with your husband on
their wedding night on your wedding
night and like when you get married to
him you don't want all these memories
with other guys
like like to me that's that's
choose carefully you mean
um i mean i would say the idea is to
wait until you're married i think it's
harder in this day and age because i
also don't think men value virginity
like we used to they used to because if
you're a top 10 20 guy
and you have like
a [ __ ] on speed dial like why would you
not why are you waiting for a virgin
yeah why are you even getting married at
all you know what i mean so it's it's a
different world but i mean i think the
ideal is telling kids to wait until
they're married if they can't if they
want to get married and have kids that's
a really old-fashioned way of looking at
it's not realistic i think
no i know a couple people that have done
it they're very happy
they're like they're probably the most
in like i have one friend like she she
waited till she was married she never
did anything like not even you know like
waiting till you know not even other
stuff yeah and she's very in love with
her husband like very in love in a way
like that i don't think i've ever seen
other girls like bond to their husband
the way that like she looks at him
i would get my um kid to like
aim for that so aim for marriage aim for
the idea of you're gonna hold out and
like if you if you hit the clouds then
that's what it is you don't get to where
you need to be and more so because
i understand that you made a great
example with the predatorial behavior if
you're saying like do as you feel if i'm
a guy who's understood the game and i
understand how to make women feel yeah i
can then allow manipulate
the girl into feeling the type of way
and if she's been taught do as you feel
i could do what i want and then leave
and that will cause her trauma
as opposed to if i've told my child to
wait it out for as long as possible
it's more so okay i don't do this
because i'm trying to wait out
for as long as possible until i get
something most guys that are trash bags
won't stay the duration and she'll be
able to filter out
the men that are not looking for
something real
and
possibly get the guy that she deserves
and i'm not saying this is always the
case but it's a good way of filtering
out
um the bad men yeah and i would also add
to that for me
the ego thing in my daughter's side i'd
have to out early it's like listen you
need to you need to clock the game right
you've only got so much time
this is the game i don't expect you to
be celibate and all that but
your time you know be careful about your
time and you need to find the highest
quality man as soon as possible and then
you try and be
the greatest version of yourself with
that guy so you want a ferrari but you
want to be a red to that guy's ferrari a
lot of girls these days think that
they're going to be like a competing car
like i'm going to be i'm going to be
like also a car and then we'll just be
together it never works in fact that's
the best way i know whether i want
something casual with someone like
when i've gotten to know them because
i'm just looking i'm just listening for
you to kind of say stuff like that and
it's like yeah we're not we're not going
to go far
that's that's how i know because she
she's actually lucky competing with me
she thinks she's going to be like match
my energy and stuff like that and i'm
like yeah but that's not a wife so
you know what something that i heard
like guys hear and like girls say that
like we think about completely different
so they call it like solacism where
girls we think everything's about us
basically so if you say oh i went to the
gym i'll be like oh i went to the gym
too and we're just saying it to have
something in common but men look at that
as you're competing with me
and i never i never thought about this
like that because as a girl that's just
how we talk
wow
that's true yeah
i mean loki you know where it's gonna go
though you know where it's gonna go when
they say certain kind of things you know
you know the narrative yeah
in too much she's gonna tell you
everything that's wrong with you and
then she's gonna go
not everyone who like when you've
injured a body part right you can't use
it
can we can we just all agree we can't
use an injured body part yeah so what
are we instructed to do not
hold on and then what heal
okay can we can we incorrect no no
hold on i'm not talking about muscles
that need work i'm talking about
internal organs i'm talking about things
that no don't don't
i'm gonna let you land i'm gonna let you
land like muscles you need to work
things need to be strengthened but
there's a resting period that's really
important and i think if we can apply
that like emotionally we might not look
at the word healing or working on self
as such an alien concept we have to look
at the body sometimes
and the spirit and the mind anyway i'm
coming with all that holistic stuff so
but also
healing right the definition of healing
is like so so something's been damaged
it heals and then it goes back to its
somewhat nearest original functionality
it's not really healing if you go on a
healing journey and now you're less
capable of loving you're less capable of
bonding that's better you're more
judgmental
you know it just sounds you're more into
yourself you start saying stuff like oh
me time i mean honestly i think it's
more honest to just say you're damaged
from every heartbreak but then that's
what everybody like
it's not that you're not gonna heal from
it like
to this you might you might improve but
like there's no going back once you've
been yeah no no no you don't you're not
you're not gonna okay you're not gonna
be better at a as a virgin at 18 or you
know some of y'all maybe earlier i don't
know 16. and
you're a virgin then you've had three
boyfriends and they all broke up maybe
one or two is toxic you're not going to
be better after you're worse
you're you're a worse product
you should put yourself on sale
damaged their cartilage and they decided
to change their lifestyle change their
diet get alternative therapy and their
cartilage well it's okay that's
regenerated
i'll give you an example so that's like
a car right that maybe you repainted it
mechanically
no it has the potential to regenerate
itself it's not not really that's why
this sounds no okay you gotta let me
talk
like
not really like you can't you can't you
can't go through three toxic
relationships and come out better you're
worse put yourself on sale and like
that's honest
and like so when guys hear when guys
hear healing like it's like a car okay
if it's got issues under the hood you
might be able to fix it but it still has
a history of issues under the hood and
you can repaint it and make it look
better but it's still a worse product
and it gets put on sale
so after a certain point you've had so
many relationships you put yourself on
set it's okay then and like honestly you
should have like it it's a sign of ego
if you say i can't put myself on sale
like who are you i don't know i just i
think maybe because my mindset is always
spiritual first like i come from a very
spiritual perspective of things so
i just feel like so if i was to say i'm
damaged okay i can say i'm damaged but
then i'm that's not going to be my story
because i don't want that to it will be
your story it will be
part of yours
i don't want it to be the thing that i'm
like oh i'm damaged so therefore i can't
do you know what i mean i'm saying you
can't coat it's just like like this is
part of your cv so when you give someone
your cv and it's like oh toxic
relationship i was so toxic i had to cut
all my friends off for six months
they're like okay red flag okay baby
like this is this girl's maybe a ten now
she's an eight now she's a seven now
she's a six whatever it is
and so it's like that's what i'm saying
once you go through [ __ ] you put
yourself on sale but then that's at
least honest go ahead then i was
thinking like when you broke up you
consider that breakup as a failure like
a personal failure it is and yeah but at
the same time i truly believe that i
learn wheat failure you can learn a
lesson so i can improve myself with a
breakup yes i will be damaged i will go
to the next relationship with a wool
baggage and they're still going to be
damaged but at the same time if i take
the lesson i can learn from that yeah so
you can improve yourself in a way that's
valuable to women but not to men
there's nothing after a toxic
relationship is going to make you better
because you've had sex with more people
you've been in more talk you probably
have more toxic habits from it and
you're older
so the things that men value you're
you're offering nothing maybe to you it
might be better but that's like a
woman's point of view because we prefer
men with experience and lived experience
because then they know how to deal
better with women because we're all
crazy
so so you it's like and that's common
you're not like the only one that's come
on the show and you know said that but
it's it's
like it's a very much a woman's point of
view is and where manners just like oh
that's baggage
yeah yeah it's quite clear as well that
like
if you talk about if you if you mention
something like you know the healing
thing and it's a toxic guy to me all
that says is that guy had an impact on
you in it like my house she's trying to
act like yeah you know i've heard him
different now i'm thinking yeah yo
yeah well my 50 years my deathbed she's
gonna be like yo but i just wanna talk
to him one more time
yeah that's what that means that's
that's what that means still i think
this idea of you can definitely
heal
um and retain
you know a lot of your value but i think
you have to have the right mindset and
today people are so self-obsessed
they take it into the more the ego
driven bit so every time they heal
they're like i'm better i'm better now
i'm better i deserve more and it's like
no you're not in fact you know you
deserve less or it could just be
instead of saying i'm better maybe it
should be i'm gonna do better no not i'm
better because you're right in what
you're saying once you're damaged you
are damaged that's not gonna go anywhere
it's also you can paint it in whatever
color you want you can make it pretty
and all the rest of it once you've had a
bad experience that is going to be then
it will go with you
but then what comes in is who you meet
how that person decides to deal with you
do you see that i mean you can meet
someone that might be a bit sensitive
towards you you might meet someone that
isn't sensitive
that makes a difference can i just add
to
you said something about how you on the
spiritual side like you're allowed to
kind of repent i don't
know i don't know is that what you meant
because repentance is basically saying
okay i'm now absolved from all my sins
okay cool but i i i understand the whole
religious aspect but my mind's more like
spiritual and you said you can kind of
cleanse like yeah you can cleanse so and
so my point would be for the cleansing
bit like you still have mileage on the
clock yeah you know what i mean yeah so
whether you've cleansed or not these
things have happened but does the
mileage sit in you though yeah yeah
violence stays yeah yeah yeah if you're
if your situation put you to a mileage
of 60 000
whether you cleanse or not you're still
at 60 000. maybe you're not trying to
get any more but like you you still have
60 000 you don't go back you can't reset
the meter on your car i don't know i
think i just have this thing about the
mind like if you could if you programmed
the minds to but i get what you're
saying at the same time that's a woman's
point of view
because because women women like a guy
that's had a past and like been through
some [ __ ] and now he's come out better
because men have to create their value
where women are born with value
so yeah so you're you're born you're
given the golden ticket at 18. even even
now you like you guys are early 30s
mid-20s like life is hard for men they
grow up being ignored most of their life
and so whereas women we're given
attention like what when's the first
time yeah when's the first time you had
a guy hit on you 13 14.
yeah
yeah
and and so we don't even realize how
hard the world is for men and how easy
it is for us where we can like spout
nonsense and nobody says anything
and we could like use all these words
and i it like i had to listen a lot to
men before i understood what they were
talking about but i'm like yeah we talk
a lot of nothing
do you know what it is i just feel like
the disconnect is like
i feel like some of you are establishing
what makes you a better person whereas
she's talking about what makes you a
better partner
you know what i mean so it's like a
better person doesn't necessarily make
you a better partner okay loudly so that
makes so much sense look actually i
think it's both actually because i think
a lot of the time
yeah i already made this point right
about what what people tend to be
think think of as making themselves a
better person it's just more and more
ego driven yeah
i think the sign that someone's healed
and someone's overcome something is that
it becomes insignificant to them okay
you know yeah someone came out say i'm a
piece of a piece of my piece i know
you're definitely not a piece you've
mentioned
it you'll just be it exactly if that's
trauma
if that trauma was if you were over that
trauma that wouldn't be a key narrative
in your life
you know it's just something that
doesn't sometimes need to be mentioned
like i looked up um what are feminine
traits nurturing soft caring playful
empathetic compassionate vulnerable so
when we're talking about healing
like all the things you guys listed none
of them got you to that like tastes like
getting rid of people for six months
doesn't make you more nurturing soft
caring playful and pathetic going on a
trip doesn't make you more nurturing
soft caring playful and pathetic
compassionate and vulnerable
yeah do the opposite yeah it does the
opposite that was wrong but that was the
information to no relationship but
that's exactly my point
like let's say you feel more confident
here but it's to a point where like
you're now shut and that you're more
masculine yeah
that's made you a more confident and
better person than yourself but as a
partner he might not be looking for that
woman who's too loud all that too in his
face it's again because we become the
men we want to marry because we like
confident men they don't they're guys
are into confident women they're into
shy women that are like reserved sweets
in any kingdom
no two kings in any kingdom yeah there's
one king it's fixed though yeah i know
cutting off people doesn't mean you're
better i think it says the latter
because when i go through spiritual
experiences etcetera i become way more
tolerant because now it's less about me
and it's more about like i see why you
did that i see i understand this so i
can handle this better so we don't have
to argue we have to fight i get it
um so if you come out of his so-called
spiritual experience and you're actually
less tolerant of everyone around you
that gives that's again lends more
credence to the idea that it's more of a
narcissistic ritual it's more like but
that wasn't what i was talking about the
spiritual the cutting off thing had
nothing to do with spirituality at all
it was more about
clean like dealing with the noise that
was in my head
it had nothing to do with like spiritual
stuff
that was for me but the whole the whole
spiritual thing is i think
often serve as a really good way to not
be accountable because spiritualism is
relative like you could make a lot of
cases and say you know listen to jada
pink and smith right
she can validate hanging with august all
day
okay she might not be a good example but
they're common and so this is this is
common whenever i hear two girls talk
about like spiritual experiences i'm
like just say you're a 304. no
i just
i'm not i don't know you so i i'm not
saying you are i'm just saying this is
i've talked to so many people in the
last six months that these are like
patterns yeah i don't know like people
that i know that are spiritual i don't
know tons but they all seem to have some
sort of level head and i know what you
mean by you're saying that people could
just say oh well i'm spiritual and dead
and they can push that onto that but
there are there are people who are
opposite sorry there are people who
are not like that there are people i get
what you're saying about being tolerable
or more tolerant
but sometimes that comes with stepping
away from the noise realizing okay what
can i do what am i sure of what can i
give what can i take back what can i
keep from us what can i give it's not
just about ego but i get what you're
saying as well
it's a give and take it's a balance of
both
if that makes any sense you look very
confused
i understood what you said okay
do you have are you sure
um yeah i understand that but to me it
just sounded like i need to be right it
kind of it kind of just sounded like
um
you know
trying to get out the fact that
spiritual practice breeds tolerance and
love
more so than anything else and it
minimizes self
and so if that understanding
if you say talk about that story i hate
to be personal
to me most of the key points of that
that your story of your spiritual
journey or healing
one it didn't make you
more loving it didn't make you you just
talk about yourself a lot you said you
know me me you know that kind of thing
it didn't make you more tolerant but i
know spiritually
experience was something else
but i think spiritual connects to
everything like we have a pattern and
you can see it in our life so your
healing journey isn't disassociated from
the action whether it's before or after
you're saying everything is
interconnected it's interconnected and
so
you know
yes you need you need time alone but
um
cutting people off again it even sounds
like a bit of a pain i need to focus on
the right things basically yeah it even
sounds like a power play like you never
hear someone a piece saying i cut people
off what did you think i meant by
cutting people off for me it was just
them not having access or availability
every single day throughout the day
sorry but when you when you hear that
that doesn't sound feminine nurturing or
soft but i am feminine nurturing i don't
think well you don't i'm saying you
don't come across that way because of
the words that you say but that's
because i'm able to articulate i'm i'm
intelligent so
and i don't think it's a bad thing for
me to say i'm intelligent but if i'm in
a man's presence or if i'm with someone
who i'm romantically connected with
my air my aura and how i i am is very
different so if we asked your axes would
they agree yeah okay and they my ex
watches this show so hopefully he's
watching any comments
whoa he told you to yeah he was the one
who was like yeah oh yeah
oh you said your order would change and
etc but you didn't surely it's other
people's
like that's like okay it's kind of like
if a man said i'm super masculine but
only when i'm around women
but so so like that's like if a guy said
like it sounds like crazy because like
if a guy if a guy comes in he acts super
like feminine right and he's like hey
like hey girls then he's like look it i
am super masculine but only when i'm
around victoria's secret models i get
what you're saying but i'm in a
situation right now where i have to
think and i have to
articulate myself so therefore maybe do
you know what maybe that's my
alpha side i don't know maybe that is my
alpha side i've run a business so i have
that alpha streak but at the same time
i've been with men who are quite alpha
and they're like they've pointed certain
things out to me so i've learned not
only through what i've seen at home with
my mom and my dad but i've also learned
through those men
and through my own journey to be more
feminine so
i'll be about loving energy it's about
patience it's about it's about all these
kind of compromise and everything you
say seems to be more around
you know
you
you kind of you know realizing power in
some way so
you know you say you're intelligent and
you're you've had a business and you cut
people off and
no but you're now listing your aura is
like different in other people it's all
a lot of affirmations and words you you
tend to you you know what to say but
feminism
isn't like i guess yeah it's a way of
being yeah like it's love in it like you
can tell you can tell when someone's
feminine but no one can tell me they're
feminine that doesn't mean anything but
everyone who knows me who experiences me
will tell you otherwise
so
because you know right now
we're here experiencing you know
remember you said sometimes you just
have to listen yeah but i'm saying like
if if everyone in the room is saying one
thing you don't think that
but this is the first time i'd be
interviewing yeah yeah yeah so
yeah but you know i guess that again
proved your point of me not listening
yeah avoid butts and try and you know
yeah it's not even just that it was also
you basic that's what i'm saying it was
my whole point of like he's basically
saying that all your points is more like
it's like a bit self-centered but it's
less as like me being a partner so
that's what i'm saying it's like you
being
all these qualities
is not necessarily like appealing to
like a man or to a relationship but i
get what you mean in terms of saying
it's better you but that's the overall
like everyone disagreeing with you i
feel like they're basically saying it's
like but to a man or to like a
relationship yeah it's not bringing much
value and you're absolutely right
because you asked me in the beginning
what is my status and i said it's very
weird and it's very complicated right
now i don't feel like i'm in the best
space to be in a relationship because
remember i just said six months
everything was off
i know that i'm still not ready fully i
know what it feels like to be vulnerable
i know what it feels like to be
com to compromise i know it feels like
to listen and all of that
i do not feel like right now right now i
just feel like i have to just focus on
me and everyone's journey is different
everyone gets to a specific place in
their life and i think as women
we are so conditioned to be like you
must give you must be loving you must be
nurturers which is what we are naturally
by birth or whatever
but i think it's also part of
self-preservation if my cup is empty i
can't pour
i need i need something for me too if i
mothers they say what do they usually
say my mom usually has time for herself
every sunday where she focuses on her
and during the rest of the week she's
able to pour into everybody in the
household and she i don't think she'll
be able to do that if she didn't take
time for her so would you say you're
still healing
there's that word again
you need to define that today man
recovery yeah because i said yeah
so technically it's not linear right
yeah but then that oh you could rewire
it as healing this so-called healing is
not effective it's not actually healing
it's more like revisiting certain
narratives
my problem with a lot of modern women is
you you've been sold this idea
by the way okay yeah but you're talking
like one but like everything okay
everything that comes out of your mouth
says modern women and it's it says it's
a lot more humbling to just say yeah
okay i might be most girls today are
modern women i'm probably modern
and it's not yeah but see like the fact
that you always have to say but i'm not
but but but instead of like listening
that's modern because femininity is just
taking in what people say
okay agreeableness yeah so
you've been sold this idea of
spirituality that that involves or
includes this level of hypergamy that
allows you to constantly reframe things
in a way that tends to suit the modern
female narrative of like
you know
me me me i'm i'm high value i'm worth
more you know that kind of thing
because yeah it just
i i did the whole like meditation you
know i was a buddhist in high school and
a lot of the results you you know
your healing doesn't sound anything like
healing to me people i know who have
actually like worked through things are
extremely calm they're extremely patient
they rarely talk you just feel a loving
aura if you meditate on the heart chakra
that's a vibe you know no one who
practices heart meditation comes out and
says yeah i'm the best lover but i love
i love i am love that kind of thing it's
not it's
the words are meaningless the words are
you trying to apply conceptuality to
something and conceptuality tends to
have ego because they have a concept
there has to be something to build that
concept on right
where that word start to define words
i get what you're saying
but you've said i was
not but we're having a discussion right
yeah so therefore you said sold the idea
of spirituality it's really like
it's such a personal thing for me like
it just made a big impact in my life
when i don't feel like i needed it i was
young i was 17 at the time and it's
something that's carried through and
whatever
but i do feel like
i've even lost my train of thought like
i can't even remember what i was gonna
say but i just remember you saying
spirituality and being sold it and i'm
just like no more butts no more feelings
just be
okay show your vulnerability
okay you were talking about that's it
you were talking about like healing and
people just going over like old cycles
right
what would then be your what would then
be your thought on someone who does
therapy that actually sees a
professional
and
works through let's say
whatever trauma because not all trauma
is an x sometimes it can be bereavement
therapy which is what one of my
therapies was for people usually think
therapy and they think ah it's an x no
sometimes it can be loss sometimes it
can be s a
sometimes it can be different things so
like
how do you view those women then would
you would you say they're just it's all
ego driven or
like depends on how you process it but
modern therapy gets it gets a bit weird
because we live in such an ideological
society that you know therapists a lot
of the time tend to push their ideology
onto the girls and these these women are
normally vulnerable so they've had a bad
experience every girl i know that is
going to be a therapist
[Music]
i should be you know i should help other
women i think i definitely no you
shouldn't
chill like
so you know this idea that we're pushing
therapy i think therapy is just a
reaffirming loop of like
ideological people then targeting weak
people their weakest point and then that
recycles because i don't know anyone who
has therapy that just stops they they
tend to have lifelong subscriptions it's
financial yeah they make they have the
same making money you're paying these
people 50 pounds an hour not if it's
free and not if you what not if you know
that you're done with that you're
getting free therapy yeah yeah you can
get free so you can get through therapy
but yeah i mean yeah
do you ever do it okay so i have a
theory about therapy it's like
this is controversial i don't know if i
want to see
i i think a lot of times when you have
therapy it's because you don't have
friends you can talk to and actually
like you can get a lot of the things you
get out of therapy from friends if you
have ones that can actually hold you
accountable but sometimes it's better to
talk to men
like i think the most accountability
i've been to therapy and the most
accountability i get is actually from my
brothers when they're like shut the [ __ ]
up you know what
and we're like a therapist i i don't
know i didn't feel the same like connect
yeah like i'll give you an example i've
been in a bad relationship before like
toxic my dad like told me aside he's
like do you like torture what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
and i was like
damn
damn dan
and it's like is a therapist gonna do
that no that's why i'm like bring back
bullying
and like honestly i think a lot of times
like the problems we have as modern
women is because we've never been
humbled in our life and i think to god i
have brothers that bullied me my brother
that called me ugly half of my childhood
thank god i might think i was a 10 right
now
and it's like i genuinely feel like a
lot of times
like the best therapy you can get is
like talking to men about your problems
because they'll actually be real with
you but they can't be men that want to
sleep with you that's bad they can't
want to sleep with you but like i don't
know like so sometimes i think therapy
is like a lack of father figures in the
home and it's like a replacement or a
strong like masculine man yeah i don't
that this is
you know don't don't hate me in the car
with all the all the people i know that
went to therapy actually my dad's right
active figure in my life and he's still
in my life and i live with him and he
was actually the first person to tell me
do you like stray dogs
in terms of men
so you know how your dad was just like
do you like torture yeah it made me stop
and i was just like okay but when it
comes to different types of therapy
sometimes a whole family doesn't know
how to deal with loss yeah so then who
do you talk to and that's the reason why
i'm like
with certain things and certain types of
therapy i'm for it i agree i'm not i'm
not like i'm not against therapy it's
just like
there's a lot of crazies
i think one of these things that i
learned um throughout my time was that
if something's free
you're the product
and so
you say all the therapy is free so
what's the
gain or where is where could be like the
game but i always learn if something's
free you're the product which means
somewhere somehow someone is going to
benefit from you having therapy whether
you see it as a positive
and then you share it to your friends
who then go okay i should go through
therapy and then go through it but
that's like the nhs
no no we're paying for that
the yeah is from also the nhs as well
like i said if something's free you're
the product
you are paying
one way that is true
so from what i've understood from this
discussion today
healing is like
a cliche no healing it's it's okay okay
healing heal go ahead guys let's just
summarize healing is a cliche
if people say that they're on a journey
it's like oh my god red flag i feel like
everyone has had that i've not heard
anyone sit not even sit on the face i've
not heard anyone say okay i hear this
but there are people that i know who
have benefited from therapy or there are
people that i know who have
that they're healing and i've seen a
difference in them or there are women
who may be very like
i don't know like
very like opinionated or alpha or this
but they also have the ability to be
feminine i've not really heard like
everyone's been so like this is their
opinion why are you looking for that
though pardon me because it would be
nice to have like a bit of range in
because i feel like everyone's kind of
saying the same i think almost i think
just as a functioning adult we can ensue
that there are exceptions like just yeah
but
nobody's saying them but no i don't
think we have to say there are
exceptions like like i can say you know
men have these masculine traits women
have these feminine traits and i don't
need to say every single time there's an
exception
like i think it can just be inferred
are you are you
when you say like like what is what came
through my head was like twitter like
for example if i'm if a woman's like oh
may not i don't want to use the wrong
word may not whatever you can swear okay
yeah or something like that yeah
then you get tons of guys who are like
not all men and then the woman will be
like yeah i know not all men do you know
what i mean well because that that is
ensuing that the exception is good man
that that's that's why that statement's
just false
because the default is most men are good
most men aren't out here graping women
they're not doing these terrible things
it's a very very small percentage of men
so that's that's just a false statement
when they say men are trash
like so so when they say not all men
like
like the statement really should be and
i've said not all men before but like
honestly the statement should be that's
that's not true
most men are most men are putting no one
in the bracket that's yeah i can say
women this and then you can always say i
don't agree with this so but but when
you say that it says more about you like
guys that say women are [ __ ] women are
this dead like it's like okay you can't
get [ __ ] shut up
that's cool because the men the men that
get girls like they love women they
don't
they don't get these and it's the same
thing with girls that are saying women
men are trash is sick no it's the men
you pick
yeah exactly so
so and that's that's on you because you
are what you attract so if you if you
attract trash man then there's something
about you as trash
i think i think a way to summarize a lot
of the different viewpoints is that
maybe your your perception of things
like healing etc aren't 100 accurate
because you just had
a lot of different opinions from a lot
of men and you know other people in
pearl who have a slightly different
perspective and you've just admitted
that you were actually looking for
exceptions when we were speaking so it
makes it clear that you weren't really
listening you were actually just
reformulating another way to
restate your original opinions
i've listened to like views that i don't
personally agree with however i'm like
do you know what
i didn't know that i didn't know about
like
the more you sleep with people
the less like i forgot what it is
oxytocin like you're able to so there's
so there's things that i'm definitely
going to go away
go home with and take away
so it's like i haven't come in with just
one set view do you know what i mean
like
i just feel like
like
with most people everyone's just been
like yeah like healing's this and this
and this and this
whereas we've just said like
we can't put things into a bracket you
know what i mean
and that's all i think i was trying to
highlight no i've said it this is what
it sounds like to men that's that's what
i've constantly said throughout this
conversation when you say that this is
what it sounds like to men okay okay
okay so no i didn't say that i think a
lot of our opinions that you've heard
when they collect completely against
yours have come not from surface level
or this is what we believe it's it's
more so
we've gone through or
me personally i've gone through deeper
levels of thought and i've come to this
conclusion and i'm bringing this
conclusion to you this is what i think
and you may look at and go well service
level that can't be right it's not a
nice conclusion why do you think like
that but i'm thinking
the problems the situations that i've
seen um environments that i've been in
have led me to believe that this is the
final conclusion that i can come up with
i'm open to change but
i hear a lot of your situations and i'm
like okay there are deeper things that
you could think about and maybe
hopefully you'll watch this episode back
and you'll see
some of the things that we were saying
because right now we're in the moment
we're all talking and more so than
anything it's upon reflection though yes
they go away
you know what's actually a crazy stat
about the oxytocin thing this is this
blew my mind so
i'm just curious what do you think the
average body count is
let's say for a 31 year old in the uk
what do you think body count
average because that's the average age
of first marriage that's right or a
woman woman sorry a woman
31
say they start having sex at 16.
i would say
what they would want to say would be
nine is probably more realistically
25 plus 25 plus okay what do you think
yeah i'd say 20 20.
i'll stay with 25 i don't know 25.
i don't know i do have deal with friends
i do but like how old are you 30 yeah
i'm 31. okay so how like friends around
your age would you say ballpark most of
them are like in long-term marriages
like
okay so so when they got married what
would you guess you don't have to four
five four five that i know okay
four or five um so
crazy thing is that when you have a
virgin and you're married you have an 80
chance of a happy marriage after 10
years
what do you think that drops down to
when you've had sex with more than five
people
20
10
10 50 45.
it's higher than you guys actually
guessed low no it's it's like 20 25
so it goes from 80 chance to a 25 chance
of a happy marriage in 10 years
i wanted to ask something you know when
you were like what would you advise your
daughters yeah do you think that
women let's say who've been like
sexually active can at some point stop
and then decide
well when i get married or is it just
not the same so i think they can stop
but i think like
god god can forgive you but men don't
that's true so so it's like you're a
used product and oftentimes like if you
come to a guy and say here's the new
price for me they're like yeah [ __ ] that
i'm gonna just go find the next 22 year
old that's available
so i mean what i see in the churches is
i see
it's like when girls do
this is what i see
i see a girl that's like you know maybe
six to eight level if i had like one to
ten yeah she's cute right dude like a
five right she she got ran through
before and she's like you know what i
need to get married this is this is this
is going south i can't do this anymore
so she says all right this is my new
pricing
and it's always the guy that's like one
to two levels below her that buys
like like just slightly less good
looking kind of like not there and so
it's like these beta dudes like that
that are buying because it's like a guy
that's like actually masculine he's not
gonna not yeah
but but like you know in a way
i mean do they deserve each other i
don't know
as long as they're happy
yeah but i just when i don't think the
girls really respect their husbands a
lot because it goes back to the alpha
widow thing they really want the guys
before
so i don't i don't know what the
solution is that's just what i see
because when i saw this in the church i
couldn't unsee it roland tomasi ruined
church for me forever
forever because everything in the church
is like gynocentrics it's all about the
woman because even in the language it's
always like like in in i had chastity
speakers i went to catholic school and
they gave us chastity speakers and it
was always the girl talking about how
broken she was what the [ __ ] you weren't
broke and you were horny let's take some
accountability
let's take some accountability for this
like i'm tired and so like even i'm like
why do the men and the men give her a
microphone
so it's like oh woman sent oh my god i
couldn't i'd see it and like it's like
basically a mating strategy because like
girls usually find god around like 27 to
30. so it's like after their party phase
and so it doesn't seem genuine to guys
because they're like oh that's
convenient right when time's running out
so
yes they're converting and they're
coming to them and saying here new
pricing and they're like ah and i i
could not unsee this
yeah
this is coming from someone i've always
like 12 years in catholic school
i i
yeah
i could not see it i also i always think
the answer to those kind of situations
of the beta getting with you know a
woman with a
with a past like that is
the man rediscovering his like
masculinity and red pill because i think
you know at some point you can't avoid
those kind of conclusions it happens but
if you're masculine self-possessed i
think you can manage it as best you can
i think when the man is feminine and is
still beta then she doesn't respect him
and then it you know she gets a divorce
and then goes from the horse to divorce
i can't lie by then it's too late
by then it's too late he he's already
he's in it too deep yeah
he can't then find
the red pill figure it out and go okay
like oh yeah like i i now know how to be
a man she's looked at him as a as a beta
yeah you're a little man now
i didn't say it would be easy i think so
he's gonna have to do it for like two
years before she recognizes that all
right maybe this guy's growing a bit i
don't think girls like once we see you
in a certain way i don't think it
changes
like we always kind of
like it's kind of like how the frick is
steph curry's wife
like how the [ __ ] is is she wanting
attention from other guys when you're
married to steph curry
i mean steph i'm trying to get some
tickets
but it's like you know what i'm saying
so it's because she got him when she was
like above him in sexual market value
even though he's her pet like that's
still how she sees him it's the same
thing with will and jada jade is like
what a five a four no one's lining up to
date 50 year olds like she looks good
for her age
someone made 18 minute video about how
ugly i was because i said jaden was a
five that was too far two four i saw it
i saw it
yeah the audacity
so don't don't make another okay
i've seen it anyways but like like it's
because she
back then they were kind of on the same
level and even though he's surpassed him
as world super far sorry she still
treats him like [ __ ]
it's like the alpha widow thing because
she really wanted the tupacs
she didn't want will he's like she goes
on and on
anyway like how how disrespectful
next level is will smith is not stepping
up as a as a man
he ain't so what i'm saying is that i
think there's always a respectable
honorable way to deal with any situation
you find yourself in he needs to leave i
don't think he can change um his
situation because jada views him in a
certain way whether he wants to be a man
in any way shape or form it wouldn't
matter it's already done so you've got
man's daughters right and letters to two
pets
[Music]
what he could leave
he
jeff bezos had the same thing right jeff
you know clearly cheated on his wife or
someone from amazon she was like listen
you know i i i'm entitled to like half
of the billions you've got and he was
like yeah take it bro yeah
he made that back see jeff bezos has
balls in it that's why i'm not saying it
can be pretty sometimes you have to hold
it out on it like listen this is
you know your girl was about but you
can't still deal with it like a
respectable man i think like it's going
to be hard but you can
no i i agree with you like there's some
accountability i heard tla talk about
though
what will smith's like dating options
are like and he's like you know what
from that guy's point of view it's like
you're just old and you're tired and
yeah you could go have the 20 year old
25 like the hot maybe 31 year old
whatever you want but he's like
then you they're going to be with their
phones and their face all the time i
don't know
i wish i'm not i'm not articulating it
right but if you ever guys ever watched
tla like the lead attorney he is the
funniest bit on this just talking about
why will smith is going to stay he's
definitely staying though yeah at this
point yeah but i think he's actually
bought her spiritual gibberish like i
think he genuinely when she says like oh
i'm sorry behind the scenes
generally he's like yeah we healing like
he has a round table talk to going out
his like personal family business yeah
he thinks he's willing nah man he thinks
he's being the bigger man by airing out
all this stuff yo he's he's in the
shadow room bro oh my gosh do you think
he just loves her he's just oh yeah
before anything happened they were the
power couple everyone loved them yeah
and i said no something's wrong look at
their kids
no no i said i said this i said this
before anyone else did i'm like mom dad
i grew up in a stable two-parent home
you guys were great parents none of us
are on that weird [ __ ] there's ten of us
you adopted three teenagers they my
parents adopted three teenagers they
didn't even raise them most of their
life and they didn't turn out like that
it's like
why why is willow or whatever wanting to
be in an open relationship and talking
about this on red table talk this is
before this is when they were the power
couple and i'm like we are not on that
weird [ __ ] and you see the grandma on
the show she's like what have i done
my grandma was like
she was coming like she didn't record
that
the grandma i saw documentary yeah from
and that like there were kids that were
talking about how they had this bad
choice in life and
the
every time they were complaining will
smith it was like it was him his fault
we've been living in his shadow because
he's a like very famous man so it was
forcing us to be captured
they were talking to jade yeah jade is
famous too they were probably talking to
jada like there's no one they're famous
no bro
he's not as famous as jay but she's
still beyonce though
jada would be nobody if it wasn't for
will
yeah they're not on the same level as
well nowhere near the same thing she's
what is she known as she's not she's
she's known as will's wife exactly yeah
because she's pretty bro
i have to rest my case on a beyonce
comparison yeah like beyonce was a world
superstar since she was
[Laughter]
no i oh my god i called this years ago
and then when all this stuff came out i
called my mom because my mom i i told
her this she's like no no not will
there's not weird stuff going on and i
called her
and i was like i told you
anyways my mom if you're watching this
um okay i'm gonna read super chats
because there's literally a lot um
guys like the video how many how many
likes we're at we're at 1k likes there's
2007 of you a 700 of you in here we need
to get to 1 500 likes come on come on
come on okay vincent dollicile jr my
wife if my wife had the audacity to have
my daughter write letters to tupac then
that to then about come get my mommy i'd
pull the plug both of those trollops
worth
wolf luffler um pearl saw the antichrist
and couldn't look away ray par pats and
pearls please make your guest stop
saying like as a filler word every two
seconds it's extremely annoying make
your makes your podcast unbearable
ramsay
spiritual sisters is on the money great
contribution to the discussion withstood
a bunch of petty criticism big up to her
zero fallout ask the ladies if getting
hit by a bus is a good idea sky is blue
water sky is blue water is wet and bad
boys don't commit these are well known
truths of the world men ain't trying to
hear the 304 saying they need to learn
tug raspberries need to make shame and
accountability great again pearl ata
guest
great guest today pearl i feel like i
like 45 percent of strom opinion um blue
collar henry nothing is free i taught my
son that when he was six get it together
ladies lifted by the wind you are
getting free therapy from your peers
sitting with you but you still resist
blue collar henry ask her if her
therapist is a woman yeah i thought so
black panther i'd say it's difficult for
a woman to maintain feminine frame
whilst debating i don't think y'all are
giving strom enough credit for being
feminine 90 free tope she makes a point
pearl confronts it she edits it mark p
perude let's give props where they're
due she's somewhat listening 90 free to
pay woman a man meets all your boxes is
is that what you love him for do women
really love unconditionally like men do
we accept you as you are 7 out of 10
times manny f what is spiritual to you
because god is whatever you place first
that's spiritual even a drug addict is
spiritual vincent dolisale jr most women
who say spiritual aren't religious
they're jada smith types believing in
horoscopes and crystals crystals not a
god most religious women normally will
mention god or some religion
specifically um soju for christ we are
at war
um like andrew tate said people say they
are spiritual in such a way as to
absolve themselves of personal
responsibility and worship to god
especially if they don't take an hour
each week to worship to god jg thank you
for the super chat um soldier for christ
we're at war you are indeed cleansed in
the eyes of god believing in jesus but
we are not a cleansed in the eyes of men
this is why this is where we make
humility great again if you aren't a
virgin you're of less value to men matt
butcher if anyone missed yesterday's
show pull it up it's the best one yet
blackest panther the only men who value
or care about your experiences as a
woman is the men you built those
experiences with every other man sees
you as a used baggage james sharp us men
don't want any woman with baggage and we
refuse to suffer the consequences of bad
men of your past heck no blackest
panther men are told that older women
have more intellectual conversations how
can i have an intelligent conversation
with someone who is delusional enough to
believe in astrology and of the wage gap
women do not outgrow that crap elijah
abdul something professionals in sport
gets get professionals in sports get
small injuries that end up being career
ending right couldn't it be the sad
couldn't the same be said for one's
heart ps gladish got his camera
oh you're gonna i thought you're gonna
say that
okay serge soldier for christ we are at
war do what feels natural what feels
good has caused is what caused all the
problems of today's society comfort is
the food of laziness courage stands on
the side of comfort beta males and 304s
do what they like 90 free tope if men
want no sex why do they still talk to
women rose i agree 100 my husband was my
first everything jessica neuville why do
women think sexual freedom is a positive
thing why do women lie that lie away the
shame if it's not negative honest
citizen pearl can you organize your
content and the full episodes are in one
section and shorts and another the
content will be easier to navigate
yeah who wants to do that it ain't gonna
be me
maybe jess
maybe jess
sentience um if if men value youth
beauty submission loyalty fertility all
the things women could have if untainted
by social media feminism and solacism
why are good men told they they win in
the end if older women have none of
those black ops good guys get leftover
women who end up leaving them 10 to 20
years with half of his net worth
manny f humankind cannot give anything
without first giving something in return
to obtain something of equal value must
be lost that is alchemy's first law of
equivalence equivalent exchange
sacrifice black is panther there's
literally a study that indicates that
women do not learn from relationship
mistakes compared to men it showed that
women do not change behavior even when
they show to regret it
the count oh i alpha widow although i've
read that one already okay well i think
um i'm probably going to end the show
because it's getting late i know you
guys have a train to make so
why don't we go around everyone um say
any final thoughts you have let the
people know where they can find you on
social media i know some of the guys
might try and slide and you're single so
so go ahead go ahead
i went silent for a minute um so any
final words basically i think we've
covered a lot about um
therapy and healing and i think the real
realistic views are we need to just
acknowledge ourselves offer some
vulnerability help each other
and hopefully we can move forward with
that um you can find me on
instagram only at amber rose barber
hi guys um
it's a great show i feel like i took a
lot of
a bit from everyone really everyone's
opinion was quite different
um i think it's really important that
everyone is accountable for their own
actions
um i think it's hard for people to do
that but i think going forward people
should try because it makes a massive
difference in their life we can't change
everyone and nor should we want to
but what we can do is we can change how
we take things on or what we choose to
have in our lives what we choose to not
have in our lives
and
think cover about
thought if i had a daughter would i
advise her to wait to have sex a hundred
percent
absolutely i think it's so important for
women to protect themselves and that we
advise them to do that because
um men can be predators and more often
men tend to know what a woman wants what
she wants to hear so we should advise
them to wait
um social media sorry i don't actually
know what it is hold on one more time
one second
okay
so it's uh underscore 2021 nelly um yeah
hit me up we can chat
so first of all thank you for having me
thank you for coming i do get like i
appreciate all the point of view and
like is a way for me to understand
and to take a lot of things home to
reflect
my final thought is that i think that
everyone should be self-awareness of
your own journey and the person you are
your limits your positive aspects and
negative aspects
and
i still believe in the healing journey
yeah so don't kill me for this but i
still believe in the healing journey
and
but at the end of the day just
call all the stereotypes and be
self-awareness and work on yourself to
be a better person and a better partner
for my i just go instagram and it's
francesca dm12
so
please not talk toxic guys yeah so just
the good ones because you know
i need to find a husband now so it's
time yeah
um thoroughly enjoyed myself the
discussion and different point of views
one thing that i took away today was i
don't know if it was you ish that said
it or if it was yourself you were like
men i think it was you men want to be
able to talk to other men here
and
they can do so but with women women like
to fix i think you said
or something like that something about
fixing or trying to give a solution and
i definitely do that so i think that's
something that i can take away like if
i'm in a romantic relationship just
listen and just
let them figure it out i'm still 100
behind healing
spirituality doesn't have to be so the
focus was about egotistic black and
having an egotistical nature and
spirituality is also about learning to
balance the ego and the pride everything
is a journey everything is a step so
those are my final words you can find me
on all socials i am linda graham that's
it thanks for having me
um yeah i feel like today was a
constructive uh conversation between
everyone
it's nice to get different insights and
just see different views and opinions
on the advice i would give is definitely
be accountable um
and just be aware like be aware of what
you bring to the table your values what
you want
and just hearing it let's yeah just all
make it happen um instagram
why there's underscore
follow the movement uptown.london also
you can find me there yeah
so names uh my takeaway from the
conversation is all i think one of the
crucial points of the conversation is be
wary of
the way society especially our current
society can misrepresent and twist
things that should be good for you um
things like healing and things like i'm
not that bought on i feel like uh or i
believe that those kind of journeys
result in humility kindness openness and
a greater capacity as a person
and so i would say be very careful
and always question the narratives
you're being fed narratives you may not
even be aware of
and
um
catch me on instagram on suntochuku
s-u-n-t-o-c-h-u-k-w-u and that means
god's warrior in iba
so i deal in truth you have a youtube
channel now right yes sir plug
modern masculine and it's just where i
give my take um on why i behave the way
i do in the dating game um and i i just
created as a way of giving younger men a
bit more scaffolding to understand why
certain guys behave the way they do
maybe you guys will watch some of my
takes and think that is trash i think
this way but the point was to open a
dialogue let's not keep this cryptic
space between why men do certain things
let's build together analyze each other
criticize each other
all right guys um my takeaway closer to
your mic please there you go my takeaway
is um
[Music]
listen to understand and don't listen to
respond it's that simple man
is you know everyone's got a lot to say
but not everyone's trying to understand
each other so yeah that's it man just
try and understand
you get a lot further in life
um my socials
instar
mueller machines underscore mgr mula
machines underscore mgr
same thing on
tick tock
um
and look me up on spotify apple musical
streaming services as gadge ga dj
running these numbers up let's put our
album out in february
14 million streams baby chase
me up
well done yeah yeah
um okay guys um also guys an
announcement i forgot to say this
earlier we're doing a members only live
stream um post show next week i believe
either one wednesday i think we said
wednesday yeah and basically me ish jess
we're just gonna eat some pizza after
the show and it's only for members so
sign up sign up for the ten dollar tier
um
i
i think five or ten i don't know i don't
know one one of the tiers is gonna get
them live stream i think maybe five
members yeah yeah sorry five and ten
okay um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel like the video on your way out
um seriously we're at 1.2 k come on we
should be at 1.5 so like the video don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
follow my instagram just.pearlythings
the facebook page the twitch page and
our new clips page we want to get
monetized on our second page so go do
that
and we will talk to you guys next time
it's like worse because of these panels
i didn't think about it when i bought
them
thank you everybody
thank you so much thank you we still got
time to get that last trade yeah
yeah i was watching the part from you
guys the dlr runs
[Music]
but everyone has their own receiving
weight
and their own conception of it their own
idea of what they take
i don't know mine might be different
not speaking
everyone has their own way of doing it
and i just feel like society has this
idea
[Music]
oh you go and you go on earth
you go on a you sit there and and
i don't know whatever you would say it
might not be that that might not be
healing for someone yeah yeah some
people contribute to distract some
people
take attention
and maybe sometimes that is what
actually
helps and everybody's different but
no i think everyone has their own ideas